welcome to this introduction to Linux
course I'm Beau Carnes and I will be
teaching this course this course is
designed for computer users who have
limited or no previous exposure to Linux
whether they're working in an individual
or Enterprise environment this course
explores the various tools and
techniques commonly used by Linux system
administrators and end users to achieve
their day-to-day work in a Linux
environment you will gain a good working
knowledge of Linux and how to navigate
through major Linux distributions system
configurations and graphical interfaces
of Linux basic command line operations
common applications of Linux and more
upon completion of this training you
should have a good working knowledge of
Linux from both a graphical and command
line perspective allowing you to easily
navigate through any of the major Linux
distributions the content of this course
was developed by the Linux Foundation
Who provided a Grant to make this course
possible I've taken their primarily
text-based course and turned it into a
video based course throughout the course
you will see some video segments that
were developed by the Linux Foundation
also you should know that sometimes
throughout this course I put Linux
commands on the screen like this the
dollar sign at the beginning is not part
of the command that just indicates the
command should be typed into the system
shell or terminal so if you're following
along type everything after the dollar
sign in the description of this video
I've linked to a text-based version of
this course
okay let's get started
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to describe the software
environment required for this course and
describe the three major Linux
distribution families
in order to fully benefit from this
course you will need to have at least
one Linux distribution installed if
you're not already familiar with the
term distribution as it relates to Linux
you soon will be you are about to learn
some more details about the many
available Linux distributions because
there are literally hundreds of
distributions I'm not covering them all
in this course instead I'll focus on the
three major distribution families the
families and representative
distributions this course will focus on
are red hat family systems including OS
and Fedora Susie family systems
including open Susie and Debian family
systems including Ubuntu and Linux Mint
I'm about to tell you more about red hat
Susie and Debian well this course
focuses on these three major Linux
distribution families as long as there
are talented contributors the families
of distributions and the distributions
within these families will continue to
change and grow people see a need and
develop special configurations and
utilities to respond to the need
sometimes that effort creates a whole
new distribution of Linux sometimes that
if effort will leverage an existing
distribution to expand the members of an
existing family
Red Hat Enterprise Linux or Rel heads
the family that includes Centos Centos
stream Fedora and Oracle Linux Fedora
has a close relationship with Rel and
contains significantly more software
than red Hat's Enterprise version one
reason for this is that a diverse
Community is involved in building Fedora
with many contributors who do not work
for Red Hat
furthermore it's used as a testing
platform for future Rel releases
and this course we'll mainly use synth
OS stream from the Red Hat Family the
basic version of scint os is also
virtually identical to Rel the most
popular Linux distribution in Enterprise
environments however Centos 8 has no
more scheduled updates the replacement
is Cento S8 stream some of the key facts
about the red hat distribution family
are Fedora serves as an upstream testing
platform for Rel Centos is a close clone
of Rel while Oracle Linux is mostly a
copy with some changes it supports
Hardware platforms such as Intel x86 arm
titanium powerpc and IBM system Z it
uses the Yum and dnf RPM based yum
package managers to install update and
remove packages in the system Rel is
widely used by Enterprise which hosts
their own systems
the Susie family and their the
relationship between Susie and open Susi
is similar to the one described between
Rel sentos and Fedora we use open Susi
as the reference distribution for the
Susie family as it's available to end
users at no cost because the two
products are extremely similar the
material that covers open Sushi can
typically be applied to sles with few
problems
some of the key facts about the Susie
family are the Susie Linux Enterprise
server or sles is Upstream from open
Susie it uses the RPM based zipper
package manager which we'll cover later
to install update and remove packages in
the system it includes the yast or get
another setup tool application for
system administration purposes slas is
widely used in retail and many other
sectors
the Debian distribution is Upstream for
several other distributions including
Ubuntu in turn Ubuntu is Upstream for
Linux Mint and a number of other
distributions it's commonly used on both
servers and desktop computers Debian is
a pure open source Community project
which is not owned by any Corporation
and has a strong focus on stability and
Debian provides by far the largest and
most complete software repository to its
users of any Linux distribution Ubuntu
aims to at providing a good compromise
between long-term stability and ease of
use since Ubuntu gets most of its
packages from Debian stable Branch it
also has access to a very large software
repository for those reasons we will use
Ubuntu LTS or long-term support as the
reference to the Debian family
distributions for this course
some key facts about the Debian family
are the Debian family is Upstream for
Ubuntu and Ubuntu is Upstream for Linux
Mint and others it uses the dpkg based
apt package manager which we'll cover
later in detail to install update and
remove packages in the system
Ubuntu has been widely used for cloud
deployments well and while Ubuntu is
built on top of Debian and is gnome
based under the hood it differs visually
from the interface on standard Debian as
well as other distributions
so in conclusion there are three major
distribution families within Linux Red
Hat Susie and Debian in this course
we'll work with Representative members
of all of these families throughout
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to define the common terms
associated with Linux
and discuss the components of a Linux
distribution in order for you to get the
most out of this course we recommend
that you have Linux installed on a
machine that you can use throughout this
course you can use this brief
installation guide preparing your
computer for Linux training it will help
you to select a Linux distribution to
install decide on whether you want to do
a standalone pure Linux machine or a
dual boot one whether to do a physical
or virtual install and more and then it
guides you through the steps I'll also
cover installation soon well we have not
covered everything in great detail but
keep in mind that most of the
documentation in Linux is actually
already on your system in the form of
band Pages which we'll discuss in great
detail later whenever you do not
understand something or want to know
more about a command program topic or
utility you can just type man and then
the topic at the command line so I'll
just assume you're thinking this way so
I won't constantly repeat for more
information look at the man page for
this topic
On a related note throughout the course
we'll use a shorthand that is common in
the open source Community when referring
to cases where the user has to make a
choice of what to enter like a name of a
program or file we'll use the shorthand
Foo to represent the to basically
represent insert file name here so we're
not actually suggesting that you
manipulate files or install Services
called Foo
the best way to learn Linux is by doing
it so make sure to try things out
yourself as you follow along you'll need
to have a Linux system up and running
that can either be a native Linux system
on your Hardware running through a live
USB stick or CD or a virtual machine
running through a hypervisor we'll show
you all these methods so let's get going
before you begin using Linux you need to
be aware of some basic terms such as
kernel distribution bootloader service
file system X Windows system desktop
environment and command line
these are very commonly used by the
Linux community
the kernel is considered the brain of
the Linux operating system it controls
the hardware and makes the hardware
interact with the applications
an example of a kernel is the Linux
kernel
the most recent Linux kernel along with
past Linux kernels can be found at the
kernel.org website
a distribution also known as distros is
a collection of programs combined with
the Linux kernel to make up a Linux
based operating system
some common examples of a distribution
are red hat Enterprise Linux Fedora
Ubuntu and gen 2.
the bootloader as the name implies is a
program that Boots the operating system
two examples of a bootloader are grub
and isolinux
a service is a program that runs as a
background process some examples of the
service are httpd
nfsd ntpd
ftpd and name d
a file system is a method for storing
and organizing files in Linux some
examples of file systems are ext3 ext4
fat xfs and butter FS
the X Windows system provides the
standard toolkit and protocol to build
graphical user interfaces on nearly all
Linux systems the desktop environment is
a graphical user interface on top of the
operating system
gnome KDE xfce and fluxbox are some
examples of the desktop environment
the command line is an interface for
typing commands on top of the operating
system
the shell is the command line
interpreter that interprets the command
line input and instructs the operating
system to perform any necessary tasks
and commands for example bash TC shell
and Z shell
suppose you have been assigned to a
project building a product for a Linux
platform
project requirements include making sure
that project works properly on the most
widely used Linux distributions to
accomplish this you need to learn about
the different components services and
configurations associated with each
distribution we're about to look at how
you would go about doing exactly that
so what is a Linux distribution and how
does it relate to the Linux kernel the
Linux kernel is the core of the
operating system a full Linux
distribution consists of the kernel plus
a number of other software tools for
file related operations user management
and software package management each of
these tools provides a part of the
complete system each tool is often its
own separate project with its own
developers working to perfect that piece
of the system while the most recent
Linux kernel and earlier versions can
always be found in the Linux kernel
archives Linux distributions may be
based on different kernel versions for
example the very popular rel8
distribution is based on the 4.18 Kernel
which is not new but is extremely stable
other distributions may move more
quickly in adopting the latest kernel
releases it's important to note that the
kernel is not an All or Nothing
proposition for example Rel instant OS
have Incorporated many of the most the
more recent kernel improvements into
their older versions as I have Ubuntu
opensusi slas and more examples of other
essential tools and ingredients provided
by distributions include the C and C
plus and claim compilers the GDB
debugger the core system libraries
applications need to to link with in
order to run the low level interface for
drawing graphics on the screen as well
as the higher level desktop environment
and the system for installing and
updating the various components
including the Cur the kernel itself and
all distributions come with a rather
complete Suite of applications already
installed
the vast variety of Linux distributions
are designed to cater to many different
audiences and organizations according to
their specific needs and tastes however
large organizations such as companies
and governmental institutions and other
entities tend to choose the major
commercially supported distributions
from Red Hat Susie and canonical which
is Ubuntu sent OS and Os stream are
popular free alternatives to Red Hat
Enterprise Linux Rel and are often used
by organizations that are comfortable
operating without paid technical support
Ubuntu and Fedora are widely used by
developers and are also popular in the
educational realm scientific Linux is
favored by the scientific research
Community for its compatibility with
scientific and mathematical software
packages both Centos variants are binary
compatible with Rel which means in most
cases binary software packages will
install properly across the
distributions many commercial
Distributors including Red Hat Ubuntu
Susie and Oracle provide long-term
fee-based support for their
distributions as well as hardware and
software certification all major
distributions provide update services
for keeping your system primed with the
latest security and Bug fixes and
performance enhancements as well as
provide online support resources
you have completed chapter two let's
summarize the key Concepts covered Linux
borrows heavily from the Unix operating
system with which its creators were well
versed Linux accesses many features and
services through files and file like
objects Linux is a fully multitasking
multi-user operating system with
built-in networking and service
processes known as daemons some of the
more common terms used in Linux are
kernel distribution bootloader service
file system X Windows system desktop
environment and command line and a full
Linux distribution consists of the
kernel plus a number of other software
tools for file related operations user
management and software package
management
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to identify Linux file systems
identify the differences between
partitions and file systems describe the
boot process and install Linux on a
computer the Linux boot process is the
procedure for initializing the system it
consists of everything that happens from
when the computer is first switched on
until the user interface is fully
operational having a good understanding
of the steps in the boot process may
help you with troubleshooting problems
as well as with tailoring the computer's
performance to your needs on the other
hand the boot process can be rather
Technical and you can start using Linux
without knowing all the details
starting in x86 based Linux system
involves a number of steps when the
computer is powered on the basic input
output system or bios and this
initializes the hardware including the
screen and keyboard and test the main
memory this process is also called post
power on self-test
the bio software is stored on a ROM chip
on the motherboard after this the
remainder of the boot process is
controlled by the operating system
once the post is completed the system
control passes from the BIOS to the
bootloader the bootloader is usually
stored on one of the hard disks in the
system either in the boot sector for
traditional bios or MBR systems or the
EFI partition for more recent or unified
extensible firmware interfaces or EFI
ufi systems up to this stage the machine
does not access any mass storage media
thereafter information on date time and
the most important peripherals are
loaded from the CMOS values after
technology used for the battery-powered
memory store which allows the system to
keep track of the date and time when
even when it's powered off a number of
boot loaders exist for Linux the most
common ones are a grub for Grand unified
bootloader ISO Linux for booting from
removable media and dos u-boot for
booting on embedded devices appliances
most Linux bootloaders can present a
user interface for choosing alternative
options for booting Linux and even other
operating systems that might be
installed when booting Linux the
bootloader is responsible for loading
the kernel image and the initial Ram
disk or file system into memory
the bootloader has two distinct stages
for systems using the BIOS MBR method
the bootloader resides at the first
sector of the hard disk also known as
the master boot record the size of the
MBR is just 512 bytes in this stage the
bootloader examines the partition table
and finds a bootable partition once it
finds a bootable partition it then
searches for the second stage Bootloader
for example grub it loads it into RAM
for systems using the EFI U EFI method
UEFI firmware reads its boot manager
data to determine which UEFI application
is to be launched and from where the
firmware then launches the UEFI
application for example grub as defined
in the boot entry in the firmware's boot
manager the second stage bootloader
resides under slash boot a splash screen
is displayed which allows us to choose
which operating system to boot after
choosing the OS the bootle boot the
bootloader loads the kernel of the
selected operating system into RAM and
passes control to it kernels are almost
always compressed so its first job is to
uncompress itself after this it will
check and analyze the system hardware
and initialize any hardware device
drivers built into the kernel
the init ramp FS file system image
contains programs and binary files that
perform all actions needed to mount the
proper root file system like providing
kernel functionality for the needed file
system and device drivers for mass
storage controllers with a facility
called udev for user device which is
responsible for figuring out which
devices are present locating the device
drivers they need to operate properly
and loading them after the root file
system has been found it's checked for
errors and mounted the mount program
instructs the operating system that a
file system is ready for use and
Associates it with a particular point in
the overall hierarchy of the file system
the mount point if this is successful
the the init Ram FS is cleared from RAM
and the init program from the root file
system is executed and it handles the
mounting and pivoting over to the final
real root file system if special
Hardware drivers are needed before the
mass storage can be accessed they must
be in the init Ram FS image
near the end of the boot process and it
starts a number of text mode login
prompts these enable you to type your
username followed by your password and
to eventually get a command shell
however if you're running a system with
a graphical login interface you'll not
see these at first usually the default
command shell is Bash but there are a
number of other Advanced command shells
available the shell prints a text prompt
indicating it is ready to accept
commands after the user types the
command and presses enter the command is
executed and another prompt is displayed
after the command is done
the bootloader loads the kernel and an
initial ram-based file system into
memory so it can be used directly by the
kernel when the kernel is loaded in Ram
it immediately initializes and
configures the computer's memory it also
configures all the hardware attached to
the system this includes all processors
i o subsystems storage devices and more
the kernel also loads some necessary
user space applications
once the kernel has set up all its
hardware and mounted the root file
system the kernel runs the S bin init
this then becomes the initial process
which then starts other processes to get
the system running most other processes
on the system Trace their origin
ultimately to init exceptions include
the so-called kernel processes these are
started by the kernel directly and their
job is to manage internal operating
system details besides starting the
system init is responsible for keeping
the system running and for shutting it
down cleanly one of his one of its
responsibilities is to act when
necessary as a manager for all
non-kernel processes it cleans up after
them upon completion and restarts user
login Services as needed when users log
in and out and does the same for other
background system services
traditionally this process startup was
done using conventions that date back to
the 1980s and the system V variety of
Unix this serial process had the system
passing through a sequence of run levels
containing collections of scripts that
start and stop Services each run level
supported a different mode of running
the system with the within each run
level Individual Services could be set
to run or to be shut down if running
however all major distributions have
moved away from this sequential run
level method of system initialization
although they usually emulate many
system V utilities for compatibility
purposes
next we'll discuss the new methods of
which system MD has become dominant
systems with systemd start up faster
than those with earlier init methods
this is largely because it replaces a
serialized set of steps with aggressive
parallelization techniques which permits
multiple services to be initiated
simultaneously it has been adapted by
all major distributions and so we'll not
discuss the older system B method or
upstart which has become a dead end
complicated Startup shell scripts are
replaced with simpler configuration
files which enumerate what has to be
done before a service has started how to
execute service startup and what
conditions the service should indicate
have been accomplished when startup is
finished one thing to note is that S Pen
slash knit now just points to lib
systemd system d
so systemd takes over the init process
one system D command system control is
used for most basic tasks while we have
not yet talked about working at the
command line here's a brief listing of
its used
think of a refrigerator that has
multiple shelves that can be used for
storing various items these shelves help
you organize the grocery items by shape
size type Etc
the same concept applies to a file
system which is the embodiment of a
method of storing and organizing
arbitrary collections of data in a human
usable form different types of file
systems supported by Linux include
conventional disk file systems
flash storage file systems
database file systems and special
purpose file systems
this section will describe the standard
file system layout shared by most
linuxed distributions
a partition is a fiscally contiguous
section of a disk or what appears to be
so in some Advanced setups a file system
is a method of storing or finding files
on a hard disk usually in a partition
one can think of a partition as a
container in which a file system resides
although in some circumstances a file
system can span more than one partition
if one uses symbolic links which we'll
discuss much later a comparison between
file systems in Windows and Linux is
shown in this table
Linux systems store their important
files according to a standard layout
called the file system hierarchy
standard which has long been maintained
by the Linux Foundation having a
standard is designed to ensure that
users administrators and developers can
move between distributions without
having to relearn how the system is
organized
Linux uses the slash character to
separate paths unlike Windows which uses
the backslash and it does not have
multiple Drive letters multiple drives
and or partitions are mounted as
directories in the single file system
removable media such as USB drives and
CDs and DVDs will show up as mounted at
run slash media slash your username
slash disk label for recent Linux
systems or under slash media for older
distributions for example if your
username is student a USB pin Drive
labeled Fedora might end up being found
at run slash media student Fedora and a
file readme.txt on that disk would be at
run slash media student slash Fedora
slash readme.txt all Linux file systems
are case sensitive so these different
ways of spelling boot represent three
different directories or folders mini
distributions distinguish between core
utilities needed for proper system
operation and other programs and place
the ladder in directories under slash
USR or user now let's learn about
viewing the file system hierarchy from
the graphical interface in Ubuntu
click the file manager icon on the left
panel by default it explores your home
directory
to see all directories under root
directory click computer on the left
places pane inside this window
double-click the Etsy directory to open
it
double-click Avi and press Ctrl L to see
the current location the current path
appears at the top of the window the
path for this is Etsy avahi
now let's learn about viewing the file
system hierarchy from the graphical user
interface in opensuse
click activities on the top left corner
of the screen corner
click the file manager icon on the left
panel by default it explores your home
directory
click computer on the left places pane
inside this window you can see all
directories under the root directory
double-click the Etsy directory to open
it
to see the current location double-click
the avahi folder and press Ctrl L the
current path appears at the top of the
window the path for this is Etsy avahi
suppose you intend to buy a new car what
factors do you need to consider to make
a proper choice
requirements which need to be taken into
account include the size needed to fit
your family in the vehicle the type of
engine and Chaos economy your expected
budget and available financing options
reliability record and after sales
Services
Etc similarly determining which
distribution to deploy also requires
planning here you can see some but not
all choices note that many embedded
Linux systems use custom crafted
contents rather than Android or octo
some questions worth thinking about
before deciding on a distribution
include what is the main function of the
system
what types of packages are important to
the organization for example web server
word processing Etc
how much hard disk space is required and
how much is available for example when
installing Linux on an embedded device
space is usually constrained
how often are packages updated
how long is the support cycle for each
release for example LTS releases have
long-term support
unique kernel customization from a
vendor or a third party
what Hardware are you running on for
example it might be x86 arm or PPC do
you need long-term stability can you
accept or need a more volatile Cutting
Edge system running the latest software
the partition layout needs to be decided
at the time of installation it can be
difficult to change later while Linux
systems handle multiple partitions by
mounting them at specific points in the
file system and you can always modify
the design later it's always easier to
try to get it right to begin with
nearly all installers provide a
reasonable default layout with either
all space dedicated to normal files on
one big partition and a smaller swap
partition or with separate partitions
for some space sensitive areas like home
and VAR you may need to override the
defaults and do something different if
you have special needs or if you want to
use more than one disk
all installations include the bare
minimum software for running a Linux
distribution most installers also
provide options for adding categories of
software common applications such as the
Firefox web browser and Libra office
office suite developer tools like the V
and emacs text editors which we'll
explore later in other popular services
such as the Apache web server tools or
mySQL database are usually included in
addition for any system with a graphical
desktop a chosen desktop such as normal
KDE is installed by default all
installers set up some initial security
features on the new system one basic
step includes setting the password for
the super user root and setting up an
initial user in some cases only an
initial user set up direct root login is
not configured and root access requires
logging in first as a normal user and
then using sudo as as we'll describe
later some distributions will also
install more advanced security
Frameworks such as SC Linux or app armor
for example all red hat based systems
including Fedora and Centos always use
SC Linux by default and Ubuntu comes
with app armor up and running
like other operating systems Linux
distributions are provided on removable
media such as USB drives and CDs or DVDs
most Linux distributions also support
booting a small image and downloading
the rest of the system over the network
these small images are usable on Media
or as Network boot images in which case
it is possible to perform and install
without using any local media mini
installers can do an installation
completely automatically using a
configuration file to specify
installation options this file is called
a Kickstart file for Red Hat based
systems and auto yes profile for sushi
based systems and a precede file for dbm
based systems each distribution provides
its own documentation and tools for
creating and managing these files
the actual installation process is
pretty similar for all distributions
after booting from the installation
media the installer starts and asks
questions about how the system should be
set up these questions are skipped if an
automatic installation file is provided
then the installation is performed
finally the computer reboots into the
newly installed system on some
distributions additional questions are
asked after the system reboots most
installers have the option of
downloading and installing updates as
part of the installation process this
requires internet access otherwise the
system uses its normal update mechanism
to retrieve those updates after the
installation is done
the demonstrations we'll see show how to
install Linux directly on your machine
erasing everything that was there while
the demonstrations will not alter your
computer following these procedures in
real life will erase all current data
there are also alternate methods to
install Linux where you won't lose any
data so some of those methods include
re-partitioning your hard disk to free
up enough room to permit dual boot or
side-by-side installation of Linux along
with your present operating system or
using a host machine hypervisor program
such as vmware's products or Oracle
virtualbox to install a client Linux
virtual machine and finally booting off
of and using a live CD or USB disk and
not running to the hard disk at all the
first method is sometimes complicated
and should be done when your confidence
is high and you understand the steps
involved the second and third methods
are quite safe and make it difficult to
damage your system
here are the steps to install Ubuntu now
going to do an install of Ubuntu 1804 as
a virtual machine under the VMware
hypervisor using a red hat seven
host system
running VMware Player
so first thing we need to do is to
create a new virtual machine
and for that I already have the Ubuntu
installed this mounted uh
in the virtual CD drive and we'll give
it a name
for the user as LF student
for the username of student
now we have to give a password
which I have done
and then for the name let's just call
Ubuntu and then on the host machine I
wanna
have a certain place I want to put it
rather than my home directory I wanted
an uh on a disk that has a lot of space
and then let's allocate 30 gigabytes of
space
and I prefer to have it as one big file
rather than multiple files or slices I
find that clutters my system less
and really that's all you have to do to
start setting up the install but it's
better to click on customize hardware
and increase the amount of memory from
one gigabyte to four and in my case and
I might as well take advantage of having
multiple processors so I'll let it use
all four processors on this host machine
and then I'll just click on finish
and it will start the install after a
couple of harmless messages about
how the virtual machine graphics driver
doesn't permit accelerated graphics
performance
now
the beautiful thing about the Ubuntu
install on this recent version
is that I am done there are no more
choices to make I don't have any more
parameters to specify Etc
if I hadn't been installing in a virtual
machine it would have asked me
information like username and password
at this stage but it was able to pick
that up because of the intelligent way
that VMware can handle Ubuntu
so I'm doing this in real time yeah if
you can read the messages you see it
just created the the main file system on
the system and now it's going through
the stage of copying all the files over
to the hard disk or I should say the
simulated hard disk
now this takes a little bit of time so
I'll pause the recording for a few
seconds so you don't have to watch not
much happening I skipped about a minute
or so and now it says it's almost
finished copying files
it's showing a bunch of different blurbs
for various features in this bionic
Beaver or Ubuntu 18.04 release
the status bar has reached all the way
to the right so it should be almost done
and now it's doing the actual install of
the system so it's copied all the files
it needs over to the hard disk
and it's doing the actual configuration
so once again I believe I'll pause for a
little while so you don't have to sit
here and watch not much happening
pause for about a minute now it says
it's configuring Hardware
so it's finding all the hardware devices
in the system making sure it has the
right device drivers for it Etc
it's now configuring the bootloader the
grub
and now it's doing cleanup it's getting
rid of packages which were only need a
journey install
then of course that's
rolling by far too fast to be readable
and so
it's doing a little bit more
package installation
and then I'll pause again for a little
while
is that it reached the end of the status
bar and now it's doing the reboot
and shortly I should be getting a login
prompt
if you notice it's installing openvm
tools that's a package
of special drivers and configuration
stuff that's used when you're running it
as a guest under VMware hypervisor
and we've reached the login screen
running under the greeter
so I'll just
well again as student
and oops I typed in the wrong password I
suppose yep
and now the system's running there's a
few introductory uh messages here and
I'll just
click through them to get
to a fully up system and then
just to see what really happened here if
I right click I can open up a terminal
and then I'm going to run the command DF
for disk free
Dash T to show me what type of file
systems have I have an H to print out
the results in megabytes and gigabytes
and I see that in the main file system I
have 30 gigabytes of space of which I'm
using 5.3 and it's an ext4 file system
when we install Centos we need to
actually specify the type of file system
the size of the partition Etc but Ubuntu
made choices that he thought were best
likewise uh we will talk about this now
but if I look at
swap files
you'll see that there is a swap file of
about one and a half gigabytes created
uh instead of a swap partition usually
distributions create swap partitions
so that's all there is to install the
latest version of Ubuntu uh absolutely
nothing to do during the install it
makes what it thinks is sensible
decisions for everything and after the
system is up and running you can then go
into the package manager and put in
exactly what you need and configure the
system in other ways if you need a more
flexible installation to begin with you
can make such choices when you start but
we we took the easy path here
here are the steps to install synth OS
we are now going to do a fresh install
of Centos
8.1 the latest version of Centos at the
time of this installation
we have already allocated hardness space
for its installation to make a virtual
machine under VMware and we have
inserted the
install disk image and we're ready to
begin
so we will uh not take the step of
testing the media and installing it
because that takes some time so we'll
just go directly to an install so I'll
just move to the first
element here and hit return
and we'll try to do this install as
quickly as possible so we'll choose
mostly the default choices and we're
going to do a workstation install rather
than a server install because this is
what is desired for this course
to happen to have a user-based install
okay so the first choice is to pick the
language we'll pick English
and then uh we can go really through any
order we want through these different
choices uh to begin with but let's just
go in order so we've already picked an
English keyboard with the US
layout and also language support is set
up for English for United States you can
click on these to make those changes
for the time and date uh it's actually
better to make sure the network is
installed first so here I'm going I
clicked on network
and I'm going to turn on the network it
found the network card and it's kind of
ready to go probably should configure
but I think the default choices will be
fine if I go to General this is all
users May connect and then if I go to
ipv4 settings you'll see it's automatic
DHCP
so that's generally what you want rather
than having to give it a fixed address
so we'll just say okay for all this and
uh
um
I guess we should say connect
automatically with priority zero that
means it'll always connect when you
start up the machine and we can say done
the reason it's good to do that before
we set the time and date is we can now
have Network time on which means it will
automatically find a time
uh
I'm currently doing this installation
from Central Time Zone in the United
States so you can try to do that with
the mouse
and I got it right it's set for Chicago
which is Central Time so I'll say done
and then uh the installation source is
uh rather important but that's local
media I already have the DVD so as you
see it's sent OS
8-1 1911 that's the latest version sent
to us
for the software selection uh let's just
keep the workstation
I could make it a server with a
graphical interface or just a server if
I really wanted to be quick I could do a
minimal install and then bring
everything up later that I need
uh but within the workstation I should
pick a few things so I'll pick an own
applications internet applications uh
you'll probably want to pick the office
suite and productivity but I'd like this
to go quickly so I won't do that right
now
uh I'll pick development Tools in case I
want to compile anything
and that's probably the main things I
need right now but you can always
change everything in detail once the
system's up so it's it's good to do a
relatively quick install
the trickiest part here is to do the
installation
um
partitioning setup so I'll pick I've
already got picked here
the virtual 30 gigabyte disk
and if I wanted to take things really
fast I would do automatic storage
configuration and let it decide what
kind of partitions that should have how
big they should be Etc and you may want
to at least look at that but let me just
do custom because it fits in better with
my needs
and then I can say done
okay and then I get to pick what kind of
installation I want to do a standard
partition and not an lvm which is
logical volume management I just want a
simple standard partition so I'll do
that
and then I actually have to create this
partitions I need so I hit the plus sign
and I'll have one big partition for
everything so it's mounted at slash and
let's give it 29 gigabytes
and I'll add that this is the 30
gigabyte disk and then I'll add one more
okay and that won't be mounted that'll
be for swap
and if I don't give a desired capacity
it should take it all
uh which it actually decided it should
have three gigabytes
I'll let the system go with what it
wants it's it's doing that based on how
much uh memory I have okay
it says I have only like one megabyte
left that'll get a total 30 gigabytes
the one other thing I get to do for the
first mound Point here is pick what kind
of file system
and you notice the default on red hat
now is Orson OS is xfs let me make it
ext4
um which is which is easier to mount
from other other machines Etc either
than xfs but you can just take the the
default if you prefer and then I say
done and
it should be done it's telling me do I
really want to do this because it's
going to wipe out everything that's on
that disc and I'll say sure accept the
changes
so uh I'm pretty much done uh K dump is
a system you can set up so that if the
system crashes your produce what's
called a core dump file so I'll just you
know you probably won't need to use that
it'll be a little faster to boot uh when
you have a new kernel so I'll just not
enable that but if you're doing a
develop machine you probably want that
we already configured the network and
under security policy we won't do any
specialization we'll just leave it alone
for now you can always change it later
and then you just say begin installation
now it'll already take a head start on
trying to load some packages and files
while you have some more information to
put in first you'll have to pick a
password for the root account
and so I'll do that
and it's actually LF train for uh
virtual machines we use for the classes
which is a pretty simple password
and uh
it's it's hard to read here but it
should be saying it's too simple I can't
see that oh it says week here but it
says press done again to use the
password anyway so I'll do that this is
a throwaway machine and then I have to
create a user I'll make the full name of
the user LF student
and by choice by default it wants to
make the username of the account L
student but we'll just make it student
will require a password to use this
account if we said make this user
administrator would be like
Ubuntu systems where there's just one
password and you have to do as you do to
do anything privileged but let's keep a
standard Unix type setup with separate
accounts and passwords for the student
user and the root user so we're going to
give a very simple password again just
the word student
and once again it's oh it says it does
not match I must have typed things wrong
let's try again s-t-u-d-e-n-t
[Music]
s-t-u-d-e-n-t
yeah so now it says the password
contains the username in some form you
will have to pass done twice to confirm
it it's also considered very weak but
we'll accept it once again it's a
throwaway machine in real life you
shouldn't do this
and so I say done
and now uh we just have to wait for the
install you'll see it is installed
500 some odd packages at a 1481. we can
keep watching while this happens but it
takes some time so I'm going to pause
the recording and come back when it's
almost done
so it has finished and it's configuring
the kernel now
uh that takes a little bit of time to
get installed I think 1481 packages
so now it's doing the actual
configuration of the kernel it is doing
a few other configuration steps you'll
notice it this is installing the
bootloader it configured the editors
is generating What's called the init Ram
FS which is uh needed to boot it
contains the initial file system which
is stored in memory for just for the
system booting which we talk about in
detail in this course
and this is probably the last thing it
really has to do before it's done uh
depending on the complexity of things it
can take a while is not complete so now
we can simply reboot
so let's do that and we should have a
running system
and you see it wants to boot there into
the default kernel
4.18.0
and I didn't do anything it will
automatically boot on its own
and then there's a few things that
happen when you start up the first time
I I wants me to accept the uh end user
license which is pretty
simple for uh open source product
um
and then finish configuration it has a
few other things
the setup
and we're ready to do our first login as
student so I clicked on that I'll type
in the password
and we have an up and running system
and uh it's going to ask us to confirm
again our choice of language
and uh we could check to make sure the
keyboard is okay but we're fine with
English us
and uh I'm going to turn off location
services that's uh that's a choice you
can make
and if you want you can connect to
various online accounts so we're going
to skip all that
then we're ready to go so now we have a
fully functional system it brings up a
tutorial screen if you want to get some
more information we'll just skip that
and here we are it's a fully functional
system
if I want to get a little information
let me drop to a command line so I
clicked on activities
I'll say terminal and here we are so for
instance if I do DF Dash h
you'll see uh I've used 5.2 gigabytes
uh and there's plenty of space available
if I wanted to change the size of the
screen depending on your hypervisor
sometimes you can just kind of drag it
out or something but here let me go to
display settings and it's set for 1280
times 780 768 and I obviously can go
bigger so just to show you for instance
let's say I take 19 20.
by 12 20.
and I'm filling up the whole screen now
it's actually bigger than my whole
screen so I'll revert to settings
but you can do all sorts of other
adjustments and we've done a complete
install of sentos 8 it's all set and
ready to use and customized to your
heart's content
here are the steps to install open Susie
we are now going to do a fresh install
of open Suzy as a virtual machine under
a VMware hypervisor on a red hat 7
system
we have already inserted the install DVD
and we're about to begin
notice that in our initial screen we can
do an installation upgrade or if we
scroll down to more
we see that we can also use the install
DVD as a rescue system
uh we can check memory and do various
things but we're going to do an install
so I'll just click on install and then
it will cook for a while before it asks
me to do anything
uh so now it's
finding all the hardware deciding what
drivers to use Etc and getting started
this is open Suzy leap version 42.3
and this is a typical gnome graphical
booting screen while it's getting itself
ready
so it should take a few more seconds
I'll pause so we don't have to watch the
whole thing okay it has moved on and
it's about ready to bring up a graphical
screen
and there we go
so it's initializing the hardware on the
system
okay now it's asking whether we want to
accept English as a language
and also the license agreement so we'll
just say sure
click on the next button
is doing more probing of the system
deciding what to do
and it says in a very small font
initializing
the installation now it would like to
take a default
partition scheme which we will override
um so let me say edit proposed settings
and I will take a partition-based
proposal
I will choose for my root partition ext4
I won't have any separate home partition
or other partitions to keep things
simple and that's all I have to choose
so it's pretty simple
and it says here it's going to create a
swap partition of two gigabytes
and then a root partition for everything
else 28 gigabytes
and so I'm happy enough with that so
I'll just say next
and first thing is just to pick the time
zone so I'll pick Central Time
where I am currently sitting
and I could do some other settings
do that unless I don't want to take
automatic time setting
so I just say next
and here I have a choice for what kind
of desktop let me pick the gnome desktop
I could pick the KDE or as a server pure
text mode no graphical or I can do
custom to do something a little more
complicated or different
and then it wants me to give up
a full name for uh the main users I'll
say LF student
and for the username I'll pick student
and I'll give a password
and then I will not pick use this
password for system administrator that
would be like what Ubuntu does and I
will not pick automatic log and it's
generally not a good idea to let your
system log in without having to give a
password
so I'll say next
it doesn't like my password because it's
too simple but I'll say okay do it and
now I have to give a root password
and you might want to test your keyboard
layout to make sure you have the right
language
I'll say next and once again it's going
to complain my password is too simple
and then I just say install and that's
all the choices
that I actually have to make so they
really nothing except specifying
username password and what kind of
desktop I want
we can do further adjustments once the
system is fully installed
now while it's installing
which should take about 10 minutes
the default screen here is a slideshow
giving you brochures and information if
I click on details it's a little more
fun to look at
so you can see the overall progress as
it goes this first bar here is for each
package as it's being installed and on
the bottom you can see I'm already about
15 percent installed
so I'm going to pause the recordings
it's kind of boring to watch it install
all 1500 packages and I'll wait until
it's asking me to do something again
before resuming
okay that took about less than 10
minutes and now it's telling me the
system is going to reboot and it did
um and so we'll just see our normal
booing
of the new open Suzy system
and it should quickly bring up the login
screen
just a few more seconds
and there's our usual greeter screen
I'll just type in the password for the
student account
and we have a fully operational open
Souza system
now the first thing I would do from here
is update the system because there's
always new updates to various packages
since the DVD installed this was
released so that's important for both
security and performance
and it's even prompting me to go ahead
and do that and then I'd probably do
some minor customizations about what
kind of menus I see how Windows behave
the keyboard Etc but I'll leave that for
people to do as an exercise
you have completed chapter three let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
a partition is a logical part of the
disk
a file system is a method of storing or
finding files on a hard disk by dividing
the hard disk into partitions data can
be grouped and separated as needed when
a failure or a mistake occurs only the
data in the affected partition will be
damaged while data on the other
partitions will likely survive
the boot process has multiple steps
starting with the BIOS which triggers
the bootloader to start up the Linux
kernel from there the init Ram FS file
system is invoked which triggers the
init program to complete the startup
process
and determining the appropriate
distribution to deploy requires that you
match your specific system needs to the
capabilities of the different
distributions
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to manage graphical interface
sessions perform basic operations using
the graphical interface change the
graphical desktop to suit your needs you
can use either a command line interface
or a graphical user interface when using
Linux to work at the CLI you have to
remember which programs and commands are
used to perform tasks on the other hand
using the GUI is often quick and easy it
allows you to interact with your system
through graphical icons and screens for
repetitive tasks the CLI is often more
efficient while the GUI is easier to
navigate if you don't remember all the
details or do something only rarely
we'll learn how to manage sessions using
the GUI for the three Linux distribution
families that we cover the most in this
course which are red hat including
sentos and Fedora Susi open Susi and
Debian Ubuntu and mint in subsequent
sections of this course will concentrate
in great detail on the command line
interface which is pretty much the same
on all distributions generally in a
Linux desktop system the X Windows
system is loaded as one of the final
steps in the boot process it's often
just called x a service called the
display manager keeps track of the
displays being provided and loads the X
server so called because it provides
graphical services to Applications
sometimes called X clients the display
manager also handles graphical logins
and starts the appropriate desktop
environment after a user logs in X is
rather old software it dates back to the
mid-1980s and as such it has certain
deficiencies on Modern systems for
example with security and it's been
stretched rather far from its original
purpose a newer system known as Weyland
is gradually superseding it and is the
default display system for Fedora rel8
and other recent distributions for the
most part it looks just like x to the
user although under the hood it's quite
different a desktop environment consists
of a session manager which starts and
maintains the components of the
graphical session and the window manager
which controls the placement and
movement of Windows the window title
bars and controls although these can be
mixed generally a set of utilities
session manager and Window Manager are
used together as a unit and together
they provide a seamless duct stop
environment if the display manager is
not started by default in the default
run level you can start the graphical
desktop in different in a different way
after logging into a text mode console
by running start X from the command line
when you install a desktop environment
the X display manager starts at the end
of the boot process it's responsible for
starting the graphics system logging in
the user and starting the user's desktop
environment you can often select from a
choice of desktop environment when
logging into the system gnome is a
popular desktop environment with an easy
to use graphical user interface it's
bundled as the default desktop
environment for most Linux distributions
including Red Hat Enterprise Linux Rel
Fedora Centos Susie Linux Enterprise
Ubuntu and Debian gnome has menu based
navigation and is sometimes an easy
transition to accomplish for Windows
users however as you'll see the look and
feel can be quite different across
distributions even if they're all using
gnome another common desktop environment
very important in the history of Linux
and also widely used is KDE which has
often been used in conjunction with Susi
and open Susie as previously mentioned
most desktop environments follow a
similar structure to gnome and will
restrict ourselves mostly to it to keep
things less complex let's demonstrate
how we log in and log out of a system
which has already been booted on all
recent distributions this looks pretty
much the same here we're showing an
instance of Centos stream which has
three users on the system and I can log
in and any one of them by selecting so
let's go with the second one BJ moose
and you'll notice that when I log in if
I click on the gear item I have a choice
of different desktops
okay here's the default on Silhouette
stream which is a Weyland but I can pick
a couple of different kinds of
x11s if I want I'll type in the password
and I log in I depending on what's going
on I may see a little bit of information
um
and that's all it's involved in logging
in I probably won't see a hell of a lot
this is a new user without much going on
if I click on activities for instance
I'll see some favorite applications
if I click on Terminal here I can bring
up a terminal if I want to do command
line activity
to log out all I have to do is go in the
upper right corner
and I can click on my name
and then I can say either switch user or
log out I would do switch user if I want
to keep more than one session active at
a time for different people which is
something you probably won't want to do
very often but it would mean if I came
back into this user session I would see
the whatever applications I had open but
I'll just pick on log out
and then I click here log out
and I'm back to my greeter or my login
screen where I can pick the users again
so I can log in on any one of them so
that's a simple demonstration of how one
logs in and out of a system each Linux
distribution comes with its own set of
desktop backgrounds you can change the
default by choosing a new wallpaper or
selecting a custom picture to be set as
the desktop background if you don't want
to use an image as the background you
can select a color to be displayed on
the desktop instead in addition you can
also change the desktop theme which
changes the look and feel of the Linux
system the theme also defines the
appearance of application windows so
let's see how to change the desktop
background and theme
we're going to demonstrate how to change
the background wallpaper on a red hat 7
system all recent Linux distributions
have exactly the same method so this
will suffice the show for all
so all we have to do is click on the
background with a right click and change
background
click on background again and then we
have a choice between
wallpapers that the system knows already
and it's possible to load up other ones
so let's say we pick this one here
and you see now the background has been
changed
or I could pick for instance a picture
stored on my machine in my pictures
directory under my home directory so
I'll pick this one
and you see it's been changed
so that's all we have to do to change
the background on any recent Linux
system
most common settings both personal and
system-wide are to be found by clicking
in the upper right hand corner on either
a gear or other obvious icon depending
on your Linux distribution
however there are many settings which
many users would like to modify which
are not accessible in that way the
default settings utility is
unfortunately rather Limited in modern
gnome-based distributions unfortunately
the Quest for Simplicity has actually
made it difficult to adapt your system
to your tastes and needs
fortunately there is a standard utility
gnome tweaks which exposes many more
setting options it also permits you to
easily install extensions by external
parties not all Linux distributions
install this tool by default but it's
always available you may have to run it
by hitting alt F2 and then typing in the
name you may want to add to your
favorites list as we shall discuss in
this screenshot the keyboard mapping is
being adjusted so the useless cap slot
key can be used as an additional control
key this saves users who use control lot
such as emacs aficionados from getting
physically damaged by pinky strain
the visual appearance of applications
the buttons scroll bars widgets and
other graphical components are
controlled by a theme gnome comes with a
set of different themes which can change
the way your applications look
the exact method for changing your theme
may depend on your distribution
for older gnome-based distributions you
can simply run gnome tweaks as shown in
the screenshot from Ubuntu however
now you'll be able to see a
demonstration for logging in and out on
the major Linux distribution families
will concentrate on in this course note
that Evolution has brought us to a stage
where a little it matters little which
distribution you choose as they're all
rather similar
recent Linux distributions which use the
gnome desktop look remarkably the same
when it comes to the process of starting
up and shutting down
so we will demonstrate that here by
using a VMware hypervisor on a red hat
Enterprise Linux host and we'll
demonstrate three recent distributions
and how they boot
so we've already teed them up so here I
will start Sentosa stream
here I will start Ubuntu 2004
and here I will start open Suzy
leap 15.3
so you'll see a little bit different
messages on each as they boot uh
according to how grub is configured and
what the possible kernel choices are it
will take longer to boot than they would
normally would if I was only doing one
at a time
simply because uh the host machine is a
little bit overloaded running three
virtual machines it really doesn't have
a ton of memory in this case I have
allotted three gigabytes of memory to
each out of a total of 16 gigabytes on
the machine so it's a little bit memory
stressed so we'll just wait till they
start and reach their greeter screen
which you see we've already done that on
Ubuntu
we've already done that on open suse a
leap and it's taking somewhat longer on
Centos uh eight stream so let's log into
these guys while we wait for sent a list
stream to get ready so I'll log in the
student
password here on the Ubuntu machine I'll
do the same thing on the open suse
machine
and now we're just waiting for the
central S8 machine
finally ready and then I'll log in there
as well
and you notice they have different
background pictures just because we have
selected different background pictures
over time but they all arrive to pretty
much the same appearance within
activities and applications menu and
then Ubuntu still likes to have this
sidebar on the left with major
applications
I can easily bring that up on the other
ones for instance if I type activities
here
activities on open Tuesday I will see
the same thing there
and then the process of shutting down is
also quite similar all I need to do
is click in the upper right hand corner
and I find the power icon
and I just say power off
I'll do the same thing with Ubuntu
again power off I'm gonna go power off
and I could do the same thing with open
Suzy
power off and power off so it's
remarkably the same from distribution to
distribution these days
it's often a good idea to lock your
screen to prevent other people from
accessing your session while you're away
from your computer no this does not
suspend the computer all your
applications and processes continue to
run while the screen is locked
let's show how to lock unlock your
screen on any recent gnome distribution
so the simplest way is to go the upper
right corner and click
refine the lock button
and simply and simply click on that and
then you can unlock it by
clicking on the display on the time
there and just typing in the password
again
very simple another way to do it is
through combination of keys uh depending
on your machine this will generally be
the Super Key plus l or the Super Key
plus the Escape where the super key is
also known as the Windows key
uh so let me do that here and once again
I brought up the lock window and I can
simply unlock it again
so that's all that's involved it's very
simple
Linux is a true multi-user operating
system which allows more than one user
to be simultaneously logged in if more
than one person uses the system it's
best for each person to have their own
user account and password this allows
for individualized settings home
directories and other files users can
take turns using the machine while
keeping everyone's sessions alive or
even be logged in simultaneously through
the network
let us demonstrate how to switch users
on an Ubuntu machine with several
accounts
so first I will choose the Linux
Foundation student as the account to log
into
type my password and sign in
and then if I look in the upper right
hand corner
and click there
I will see LF student
and I can click on either log out or
switch user notice if I log out I really
log out but if I switch user I will just
lock the user account and then when I
start up I will preserve all my sessions
and open Windows Etc when I restart
on some distributions you may actually
see a list of users at this screen but
not on Ubuntu
so I'll say switch user back to the
greeter screen
and let me pick the second one Theodore
cleaver
and login as that other user
and there we go and now if I look up
here again I can do the same thing
so let me click on the name and I'll say
switch user
and if I pick student again you notice
here it says unlock and not restart that
means that if I were to log in now I
will have preserved all the open windows
and running applications from before
this will look the same essentially on
all Linux distributions of recent
vintage so it's very easy to switch
users and not lose any information from
what you're already doing
besides normal daily starting and
stopping of the computer a system
restart may be required as part of
certain major system updates generally
only those involving installing a new
Linux kernel initiating the shutdown
process from the graphical desktop is
rather trivial on most current Linux
distributions with very little variation
we'll discuss later how to do this from
the command line using the shutdown
command in all cases you click on either
a settings or gear or a power icon and
follow the prompts to shut down the
computer on any recent gnome based Linux
distribution perform the following steps
first click the power or the gear icon
in the upper right hand corner of the
screen
second click on click on the power off
restart or cancel
if you do nothing the system will shut
down in 60 Seconds
shut down reboot and log out operations
will ask for confirmation before going
ahead this is because many applications
will not save their data their data
properly when terminated this way always
save your documents and data before
restarting shutting down or logging out
all modern computer support suspend or
sleep mode when you want to stop using
your computer for a while
suspend mode saves the current system
State and allows you to resume your
session more quickly while remaining on
but uses very little power in the
sleeping state it works by keeping your
system's applications desktop and so on
in system Ram but turning off all the
other Hardware this shortens the the
time for a full system startup as well
as conserves battery power once note
that modern Linux distributions actually
boot so fast that the amount of time
saved is often minor
even experienced users can forget the
precise command that launches an
application or exactly what options and
arguments it requires fortunately Linux
allows you to quickly open applications
using the graphical interface
applications are found at different
places in Linux and with a gnome
they can be found from the applications
menu in the upper left hand corner or
from the activities menu in the upper
left hand corner
also in some Ubuntu versions from the
dash button in the upper left hand
corner for KDE and some other
environments applications can be opened
from the button in the lower left hand
corner in the upcoming sections you will
learn how to perform basic Linux
operations using the graphical interface
unlike other operating systems the
initial install of Linux usually comes
with a wide range of applications and
software archives that contain thousands
of programs that enable you to
accomplish a wide variety of tasks with
your computer
for most key tasks a default application
is usually already installed however you
can always install more applications and
try different options
for example Firefox is popular as the
default browser in many Linux
distributions while Epiphany concodor
and chromium the open source of Google
Chrome are usually available for install
from software repositories proprietary
web browsers such as Opera and chrome
are also available locating applications
from The Gnome and KDE menus is easy as
they're neatly organized and functional
sub-menus
multiple applications are available to
accomplish various tasks and to open a
file type of a file of a given type for
example you can click on a web address
while reading an email and launch a
browser such as Firefox or Chrome
to set the default applications enter
the settings menu on all recent Linux
distributions and then click on either
default applications or details default
applications
let's now demonstrate how to set default
applications on a red hat system
we go to the upper right hand corner
click on the top bar then scroll down to
the gears icon for settings
go down to the bottom for details
and then I can click on default
applications
so you see under web or browser there
are three choices on this system I have
Google Chrome Firefox or Opera we'll
leave it at Google Chrome
for video the default choices videos
which is actually a program called totem
but let's switch it to the VLC media
player
and for the image viewer I have the
built-in image viewer or I could switch
to the new image manipulation program
better known as
so on all recent distributions with a
known desktop
the procedure is identical and
absolutely the same and it's very simple
to change your default applications
each distribution implements the
Nautilus or file manager utility which
is used to navigate the file system it
can locate files and when a file is
clicked upon either it will run if it's
a program or an associate application
will be launched using the file as data
this behavior is completely familiar to
anyone who has used other operating
systems to start the file manager you
will have to click on its icon a file
cabinet which is easily found usually
under favorites or accessories it will
have the name files this will open a
window with your home directory
displayed
the left panel of the file manager
window holds a list of commonly used
directories such as desktop documents
downloads and pictures
the file manager lets you access
different locations on your computer and
the network including the home directory
the desktop documents pictures and other
other locations every user with an
account on the system will have a home
directory usually created under home
slash home usually named according to
the user such as slash home student by
default files the user saves will be
placed in a Directory Street starting
there account creation whether during
system installation or at a later time
when a new user is added also induces
default directories to be created under
the user's home directory such as
documents desktop and downloads
the file manager allows you to view
files and directories in more than one
way
you can switch between the icons and
list formats either by clicking The
Familiar icons in the top bar or you can
press Ctrl 1 or control 2 respectively
in addition you can also arrange the
files and directories by name size type
or modification to date for future
sorting to do so click View and select
arrange items another useful option is
to show hidden files sometimes and
precisely called system files which are
usually configuration files that are
hidden by default and whose name starts
with a DOT to show him file select show
hidden files from the menu or press Ctrl
H the file browser provides multiple
ways to customize your window view to
facilitate easy drag and drop file
operations you can also alter the size
of the icons by selecting zoom in and
zoom out under the view menu the file
manager includes a great Search tool
inside the file browser window
one click search in the toolbar to bring
up a text box then enter the keyword in
this text box this causes the system to
perform a recursive search from the
current directory for any file or
directory which contains a part of this
keyword
you can refine your search beyond the
initial keyword by providing drop down
menus to further filter the search
deleting a file in Nautilus will
automatically move the deleted file to
the local share slash trash files
directory basically a trash can under
the user's home directory there are
several ways to delete files and
directories under Nautilus
one you can select all you select all
the files and directories that you want
to delete then press Ctrl delete on your
keyboard or right click the file
then select move to trash
note that you may have a delete
permanently option which bypasses the
trash folder and this option may be
visible all the time or only in list
rather than icon mode to permanently
delete a file on the left panel inside a
nautilus file browser window right click
on the trash the on the trash directory
select empty trash
and that's all alternatively select the
file or directory you want to
permanently delete and press shift
delete
let's see how to locate the Firefox
application in locate Firefox
click activities on the top left corner
of your desktop on the left panel click
the show applications icon click the
Firefox icon
close Firefox by clicking close in the
top right corner of the Firefox window
next let's explore the home directory
using the file manager try to View files
in list mode create a new empty document
save it and remove it
click activities in the upper left
corner of your desktop
in the left panel click the file manager
icon
this will by default open the home
directory to View files in list mode
click the list icon in the upper right
of the file manager window
double-click the document directory to
open it click activities in the top left
corner of your desktop to launch G edit
type G edit in the search box
click the G edit icon to open it
type your name and click close in the
top right corner of the G edit window to
create and close a file
click save as to save the created file
select documents from the left panel of
the save as window
type test to save the file by that name
click save to save the file and close G
edit this brings you back to the
document directory right-click the test
file in the document window select move
to trash to remove the file
you have completed chapter 4. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered gnome
is a popular desktop environment and
graphical user interface that runs on
top of the Linux operating system
the default display manager for Gnome is
called gdm the gdm display manager
presents the user with the login screen
which prompt for the user the login
username and password
log out through the desktop environment
kills all processes in your current X
session and returns to the display
manager login screen
Linux enables users to switch between
logged in sessions so spending puts the
computer into sleep mode
for each key task there is generally a
default application installed
every user created in the system will
have a home directory
the places menu contains entries that
allow you to access different parts of
the computer and the network
Nautilus gives three formats to View
files
each Linux distribution comes with its
own set of desktop backgrounds
gnome comes with a set of different
themes which can change the way your
applications look
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to apply system display and date
and time settings using the system
settings panel
track the network settings and manage
connections using the network manager in
Linux
install and update software in Linux
from a graphical interface
note that we'll revisit all these tasks
later when we discuss how to accomplish
them from the command line
the system settings panel allows you to
control most of the basic configuration
options and desktop settings such as
specifying the screen resolution
managing network connections or changing
the date and time of the system
for The Gnome desktop manager one clicks
on the upper right hand corner and then
selects the tools image the screwdriver
crossed with a wrench or gear depending
on your distribution you may find other
ways to get into the settings
configurations as well you'll also find
variations in the menu layout between
Linux distributions and versions so you
may have to hunt for the settings you
need or to examine or modify
to get deeper into configuration one can
click on the devices on the previous
menu in order to configure items like
the display the keyboard the printers
Etc one can also click on the users icon
which may be under details to set values
for system users such as their login
picture password Etc
a lot of personalized configuration
settings do not appear on the settings
menu instead you have to launch a tool
called either gnome tweaks or gnome
tweak tool we have not really discussed
working at the command line yet but you
can always launch a programs such as
this by doing alt F2 and typing in the
command
some distributions have a link to the
tweaks menu and the settings but for
some mysterious reason many obscure this
Tool's existence and it becomes hard to
discover how to modify even rather basic
desk type attributes and behaviors
important things you can do with this
tool include selecting a theme
configuring extensions which you can get
from your distribution or download from
the internet you can control fonts
modify the keyboard layout and set which
programs start when you log in the most
recent gnome versions have removed a lot
of the functionality of gnome tweaks
extensions now have to be configured
using a new a new app called gnome
extensions app the reasoning for this is
obscure here you can see a screenshot
from a red hat system with quite a few
extensions installed but not all being
used
clicking on settings displays or
settings devices displays will expose
the most common settings for changing
the desktop appearance these settings
function independently of the specific
display drivers you're running the exact
appearance will depend enormously on how
many monitors you have and other factors
such as Linux distribution and
particular version
if your system uses a proprietary video
card driver usually from Nvidia or AMD
you'll probably have a separate
configuration program for that driver
this program may give more configuration
options but may also be more complicated
and might require this admin root access
if possible you should configure the
settings in the displays panel rather
than with the proprietary program
the X server which actually provides the
the GUI uses slash Etc X11 xorg.com as
its configuration file if it exists in
modern Linux distributions this file is
usually present only in unusual
circumstances such as when certain less
common graph drivers are in use changing
this configuration file directly is
usually for more advanced users
while your system will usually figure
out the best resolution for your screen
automatically it may get this wrong in
some cases or you might want to change
the resolution to meet your needs
you can accomplish this using the
displays panel the switch the switch to
the new resolution will be effective
when you click apply and then confirm
that the resolution is working in case
the selected resolution fails to work or
you're just not happy with the
appearance the system will switch back
to the original resolution after a short
timeout once again the exact appearance
of the configuration screen will vary a
lot between distributions and versions
but usually it's rather intuitive and
easy Once you find the configuration
menus
in most cases the configuration for
multiple displays is set up
automatically as one big screen spanning
all monitors using reasonable guests for
screen layout if the screen layout is
not as desired a checkbox can turn on
mirrored mode where the same display is
seen on all monitors clicking on a
particular monitor image lets you
configure the resolution of each one and
whether they make one big screen or
mirror the same video configuring
display settings such as resolution is
almost identical on all major
distributions so we'll demonstrate that
running virtual machines under VMware on
a red hat 8 host
so let's begin with showing what it
looks like on Ubuntu
so I go up in the upper right hand
corner and I find the settings button
and then in the main uh panel here we
have displays so we've already clicked
on that
and you see uh the easiest thing to do
here is I can change the resolution to
be any one of these numbers
now you can continuously vary the
display size usually on a virtual
machine
and by dragging and dropping the corners
you see now it's changed to another
number but that's all that's involved in
Ubuntu for instance
if I want to go to open well let's try
Centos
incentives 8 stream actually I find the
settings once again and then here I have
to scroll down to devices
and then displaces in there and we have
the identical setup except for this
night light option which is for looking
in a darker situation which we also had
in the Ubuntu was just located in a
different place
on open Tuesday
you'll see it's virtually identical as
well I just click on the settings gear
button here
and once again I have to go to devices
like I did on the red hat system and I
have the identical situation you
couldn't tell what operating system you
were on if you just looked at this
now these are all virtual machines with
one terminal if I look on the host which
actually has three different monitors
hooked up to it
you'll see then I get something like
this
where I can see all three of my monitors
uh I can figure any one of them here
it's doing those the smaller one the 18
inch one but I could switch to the 27 or
the 24
and I can control their different
resolutions if I move these guys around
here I can change the way the three of
them are laid out for left to right I
don't particularly want to do that
because it gets kind of messy but this
is how you can control which ones in the
middle which is on the right or left Etc
so these days configuring the display
resolution and some other basic things
is really very simple very intuitive the
hardest thing is just to find the the
settings icon to click on
by default Linux always uses coordinated
universal time for its own internal time
keeping displayed or stored time values
rely on the system time zone setting to
get the proper time UTC is similar to
but more accurate than Greenwich Mean
Time
if you click on the time displayed on
the top panel you can adjust the format
with which the date and time is shown on
some distributions you can also alter
the values the more detailed date and
time settings can be selected from the
date and time window in the system
settings menu the automatic settings are
referring to the use of network time
protocol which we'll discuss next
the network time protocol is the most
popular and reliable protocol for
setting the local time by Consulting
established internet servers Linux
distributions always come with a working
ntp setup which refers to a specific
time servers run or relied on by the
distribution this means that no setup
Beyond on or off is generally required
for Network time synchronization
all Linux distributions have network
configuration files but file formats and
locations can differ from one
distribution to another hand editing of
these files can handle quite complicated
setups but it's not very dynamic or easy
to learn and use network manager was
developed to make things easier and more
uniform across distributions it can list
all available networks both wired and
wireless allow the choice of a wired
Wireless or a mobile broadband Network
handle passwords and set up virtual
private Networks except for unusual
situations it's generally best to let
network manager establish your
connections and keep track of your
settings in this section you'll learn
how to manage network connections
including wired and wireless connections
and mobile broadband and VPN connections
wired connections usually do not require
complicated or manual configuration the
hardware interface and Signal presence
are automatically detected and then
network manager sets the actual network
settings via Dynamic host configuration
protocol or DHCP
for static configurations that do not
use DHCP manual setup can also be done
easily through network manager you can
also change the Ethernet Mac address or
media Access Control address if your
Hardware supports it the MAC address is
a unique hexadecimal number of your
network card wireless networks are
usually not connected by default you can
view the list of available wireless
networks and see which one if any you're
currently connected to by using network
manager you can then add edit or remove
known wireless networks and also specify
which ones which ones you want connected
by default when present
to configure a wireless network in any
recent gnome-based distribution
click on the upper right corner of the
top panel which brings up a settings and
or network window while the exact
appearance will depend on Linux
distribution inversion it will always be
possible to click on a Wi-Fi Sub menu as
long as the hardware is present here is
an example from a rel8 system
select the wireless network you wish to
connect to if it's a secure network the
first time it will request that you
enter the appropriate password by
default the password will be saved for
subsequent connections if you click on
Wi-Fi settings you will bring up this
if you click on the gear icon for any
connection you can configure it in more
detail
older and other Linux distributions may
look quite a bit different in detail but
the steps and choices are essentially
identical as they're all running network
manager with perhaps somewhat different
clothing
let's demonstrate
how to control wired and wireless
network connections on a red hat system
if I click on the upper right hand
corner for instance if I want to look at
the wired connection I can just scroll
down to the wired connection
and then wired settings
and it asks me for my password
the root the root password because it
wants
to have a super user only control
network connections
and you'll see I have a thousand megabit
connection
if I click on the gear icon I can
control the settings
on the details first screen it says it
connects automatically when the system
starts and all users can use it
on identity I give what the name of the
interface looks like not the name of the
system
in older systems that would have been
eth0 eth1 Etc but as we will discuss
later newer systems have these more
complex names
under ipv4 we control the basic Internet
Protocol systems settings
most of the time you'll leave it alone
it automatically hcp Dynamic host
configuration protocol
where the system figures out its address
from the server Etc if you understand
how the importance of manual settings
you can specify an address a net mask a
Gateway you can select a particular DNS
server and you can specify routes to
certain addresses
if you understand those Concepts this is
where you would go to control all that
we're not changing anything so I'll just
hit cancel
now if I want to control Wi-Fi settings
I could go back to that upper right
corner or I can just click on
the Wi-Fi setting here and once again
it's asking me for the
super user password
these are the different wireless
networks that have to be that are
available at the moment they all have
lots next to them means they require a
password this is the one that I'm
actually on coopj the first one
if I click on the settings there once
again it's going to ask me
for um
my my super user password and I see
essentially the exact same settings I
had on the wired connection
the automatic startup as other people
use it the identity and whether I want
to use DHCP or set things manually or
not
so that's all there really is in the
graphical interface to control basic
network connections it's rather simple
and it looks the same at all recent
Linux distributions
you can set up mobile broadband
connection with network manager which
will launch a wizard to set up the
connection details for each connection
once the configuration is done the
network is configured automatically each
time the Broadband network is attached
network manager can also manage this
manage your VPN connections it supports
many VPN Technologies such as native
ipsec Cisco open connect via either the
Cisco client or a native open source
client Microsoft pptp and openvpn
you might get support for a VPN as a
separate package from your distributor
you need to install this package if your
preferred VPN is not supported
each package and Linux distribution
provides one piece of the system such as
the Linux kernel the C compiler
utilities for manipulating text or
configuring the network or for your
favorite web browsers and email clients
packages often depend on each other for
example because your email client
communicates using SSL TLS it will
depend on a package which provides the
ability to encrypt and decrypt SSL and
TLS communication and will not install
unless that package is also installed at
the same time
all systems have a lower level utility
which handles the details of unpacking a
package and putting the pieces in the
right places most of the time you will
be working with a higher level utility
which knows how to download packages
from the internet and can manage
dependencies and groups for you
in this section you will learn how to
install and update software in Linux
using the dbn packaging system used by
systems such as Ubuntu as well and RPM
Packaging Systems which is used by both
red hat and the Susie family systems
there are these are the main ones and
use although there are other ones which
work well for other distributions which
are less used
let's look at the package management for
the Debian family system
dpkg is the underlying package manager
for these systems it can install remove
and build packages unlike high-level
packages Management Systems it does not
automatically download and install
packages and satisfy their dependencies
for deviant based systems the higher
level package management system is the
advanced package tool or apt system of
utilities generally while each
distribution within the Debian family
uses apt it creates its own user
interface on top of it for example
aptkit or app kit synthetic Ubuntu
software sensor Etc although apt
repositories are generally compatible
with each other the software they
contain generally is not therefore most
repositories Target a particular
distribution like Ubuntu and often
software Distributors ship with multiple
repositories to support multiple
distributions demonstrations are shown
later in this section
Red Hat package manager or RPM is the
other package management system popular
on Linux distributions it was developed
by red hat and adopted by a number of
other distributions including Sushi and
open Sushi OS Oracle Linux and others
the high level package manager differs
between distributions Red Hat Family
distributions historically use Rel or
syn Os and Fedora uses dnf while
retaining good backward compatibility
with the older yum program Susie family
distributions such as open Susi also use
RPM but use the zipper interface
the yet another setup tool or yes
software manager is similar to other
graphical package managers it's an RPM
based application you can add remove or
update packages using this application
very easily to access the yes software
manager first click activities
then in the search box type yeast and
click on the yes icon then click
software management you can also find
yes by clicking on applications other
guest which is a strange place to put it
but open sources yes software management
application is similar to The graphical
package managers and other distributions
a demonstration of the yes software
manager is seen later in this section
we are now going to demonstrate software
package management from a graphical
interface
using the open Suzy Linux distribution
the tool we want to use for doing this
is yes yast and there's two different
ways I can reach it if I have the gnome
shell extension installed which shows
the applications menu which doesn't come
by default
I can go down to systems tools and then
go down to yes
or I can always go up
to the upper right hand corner click on
the tool icon
and then at the bottom here on the
system click on yes
it will want the root password because
I'm going to manipulate what's installed
on the system
and so if I go to software I can go to
software management
now the first thing that yes has to do
is study the system and get a database
of every possible package
so it you can look at the packages on
the system in different ways
you can look by what's called RPM groups
so here's all the games and are grouped
under Amusements
I have applications development and all
different kinds of development
subcategories
tools documentation Etc or RPM groups
that is rpm groups okay
or I can look at package groups which
maybe is a little more intuitive
so I could click on let's say multimedia
and see all the different programs are
involved in uh in dealing with
multimedia
suppose I want to install something or
inquire as to where something is
installed I can click on search
and type something in here I'll type the
new plot
and I bring up quickly all the different
canoe plot uh pro programs there are the
main one you see has a check mark in the
box that means it's already installed
[Music]
um
I will decide to install gnu plot.doc
which is a small documentation package
and then in order to do the install I
will click on accept
and it will go ahead and do it it's a
pretty small package it doesn't take
long if you needed some other packages
to function it would have installed them
at the same time
so now I'll say continue
and if I could want to remove it because
I don't really need it I'll type it that
in the search again
and then I click on here
um
until I get an X for removal
and then I say accept
and it's removing it so that's all I had
to do to do some basic package
installation and removal under gnome
software with open Susie pretty simple
experienced Linux administrators
probably do most of their package
management from the command line rather
than from a graphical interface
however every Linux distribution has at
least one graphical interface for
installing upgrading removing Etc
various software packages
so let's take a look at a recent Ubuntu
system
I can go to Applications and then down
to system tools and first let's look at
the one at the bottom here which just
says software
this is actually a program called gnome
software you can always install it if it
hasn't been installed on your system it
looks somewhat like an app store or a
Play Store from Android and it's pretty
obvious you can click on any one of
these to try to install Etc and at the
bottom you'll see things are grouped by
category so for instance oh I could
click on utilities
and then I'll see a bunch of different
utilities that may or may not be
installed on your system already okay
or I could search for various things so
let me go back to the main page and
um
if I click on The Hourglass up in the
corner here I can search
so let's say I search on Terminal
here you'll see it'll come up with a
number of different things I could
install
you'll see here this terminal here is
the gnome terminal that it says
installed in a rather small font here
uh and if I wanted to install something
else I could just say for instance here
I could click on that and I would say
install and it could just be installed
or if I want something a little more fun
let's say
look for a program called cheese
which lets you use your
webcam to take pictures or or make
videos Etc and I can say remove because
it turns out it's already installed so
let me remove it
and it's going to want a password to do
this which should be that price
surprising
so I type my password and it's removing
it
and then uh
you know if I want to reinstall it which
I'll do I'll just say install and give
the password again
so this is not a very complex
program to use uh it's pretty easy to
use Canon software and you'll notice at
the top you have a list here of explore
which is where we are now installed
would be all your installed packages
and if you do updates it's telling me
the system has two sets of updates that
I really should install but to save time
I'll do that right now
so that's one graphical interface
there's a much older graphical interface
that's available in Ubuntu called
synaptic so let's do that one
photo is under system tools there we go
synaptic package manager
and once again this is going to ask
for a password
and uh it's an informatory message and
this is actually a very simple easy to
use and uh gives you a clearer
uh vision of exactly where everything
came from
compared to the more modern graphical
interfaces
it's pretty straightforward to use
um it's organized by either sections
here I can do it in other ways I can do
searching uh uh Etc so suppose I want to
search I'll do the same search here
terminal
and it's going to show me all the
packages that either have terminal the
name or discuss terminal if I want to
restrict it to ones that have only
uh in the name I can do that
and it's pretty straightforward to use I
won't run through this these are already
installed because they're in green
uh I can install any of these other ones
and I can just click on that and then I
will say I want to do QT terminal
I would say Mark for installation
and it says in order to this the work it
has to install all these other packages
too which it depends on so we won't
bother to do that and that's briefly
what you can do on an Ubuntu system with
a graphical software package
installations and removals
you have completed chapter five so let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
you can control basic configuration
options and desktop settings through the
system settings panel
Linux always uses coordinated universal
time or UTC for its own internal
timekeeping you can set the date and
time settings from the system settings
window
the network time protocol is the most
popular and reliable protocol for
setting the local time via internet
servers
the displays panel allows you to change
the resolution of your display and
configure multiple screens
the network manager can present
available wireless networks it allows
the choice of a wireless or mobile
broadband Network handles passwords and
sets up vpns the dpkg and RPM are the
most popular package Management Systems
used on Linux distributions
deviant distributions use dpkg and
apt-based utilities for package
management RPM was developed by red hat
and adopted by a number of other
distributions including open succe
Oracle Linux and others
by the end of this chapter you should be
familiar with common Linux applications
including internet applications such as
browsers and email programs office
productivity Suites such as Libra office
developer tools such as compilers
debuggers Etc multimedia applications
such as those for audio and video
graphic editors such as the and
other Graphics utilities
the internet is a Global Network that
allows users around the world to perform
multiple tasks such as searching for
data communicating through emails and
online shopping obviously you need to
use Network aware applications to take
advantage of the internet
these include web browsers email clients
streaming media applications Internet
relay chats and conferencing software
as discussed in the graphical interface
chapter Linux offers a wide variety of
web browsers both graphical and text
space
including Firefox Google Chrome chromium
Epiphany renamed web conquer
links lynx w3m and Opera
email applications allow for sending
receiving and reading messages over the
Internet Linux systems offer a wide
number of email clients both graphical
and text-based in addition many users
simply use their browsers to access
their email accounts most email clients
use the internet message access protocol
or IMAP or the older pop post office
protocol to access email stored on a
remote mail server most email
applications are we also display HTML
formatted emails that include objects
like pictures and hyperlinks Linux
support the following types of email
applications
graphical email clients such as
Thunderbird Evolution and Clause mail
text mode email clients such as Mutt and
mail
all web browser-based clients such as
Gmail Yahoo mail and office 365.
Linux systems provide many other
applications for performing internet
related tasks
these include filezilla pigeon ikiga and
hexchat
most day-to-day computer systems have
productivity applications sometimes
called office suites available or
installed each Suite is a collection of
closely coupled programs used to create
and edit different types of files such
as text
spreadsheets presentations graphical
objects
most Linux distributions offer a Libra
office an open source office suite that
started in 2010 and has evolved from
open Office while other office suites
are available as as we have listed
LibreOffice is the most mature and it's
most it's also the most widely used and
intensely developed in addition Linux
users have full access to internet-based
office suites such as Google Docs and
Microsoft Office 365.
the component applications included in
Libra office are writer for word
processing calc for spreadsheets impress
for presentations draw for creating and
editing graphics and diagrams the
LibreOffice applications can read and
write non-native document formats such
as those used by Microsoft Office
usually Fidelity is maintained quite
well but complicated documents might
have some imperfect conversions
Linux distributions come with a complete
set of applications and tools that are
needed by those developing or
maintaining both user applications and
the kernel itself these tools are
tightly integrated and include Advanced
editors customized for programmers needs
such as V and emacs compilers for every
computer language that has ever existed
including very popular or new ones such
as golang and rust debuggers such as GDB
and various graphical front ends to it
and other and many other debugging tools
performance measuring and monitoring
programs some with easy to use graphical
interfaces others more Arcane and meant
to be used only by serious experienced
development Engineers complete
integrated development environments or
Ides such as eclipse and visual studio
code that put all these tools together
another operating systems these tools
have to be obtained and installed
separately often at a high cost well in
licks they are all available at no cost
through standard package installation
systems
multimedia applications are used to
listen to music watch videos
Etc as well as to present and view text
and Graphics Linux systems offer a
number of sound player applications
including amarok audacity and Rhythm box
of course Linux systems can also connect
with commercial online music streaming
services such as Pandora and Spotify
through web browsers
movie and video players can portray
input from many different sources either
local to the machine or on the Internet
Linux systems offer a number of movie
players including VLC and player zine
totem
movie editors are used to edit videos or
movies like systems offer a number of
movie editors including cinepaint
blender Cinderella and ffmpeg
graphic editors allow you to create edit
View and organize images of various
formats the new image manipulation
program or is a feature-rich image
retouching and editing tool similar to
Adobe Photoshop and it's available on
all Linux distributions some features of
of are it can handle any image
format it has many special purpose
plugins and filters it provides
extensive information about the image
such as layers channels and histograms
in addition to there are other
Graphics utilities that help perform
various image related tasks
including EOG inkscape convert and
scribus
you have completed chapter six let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
Linux offers a wide variety of Internet
applications such as web browsers email
clients online media applications and
others
web browsers supported by Linux can be
either graphical or text-based such as
Firefox Google Chrome Epiphany w3m links
and other others
Linux supports graphical email clients
such as Thunderbird Evolution and
cosmile and text mode email clients such
as Mutt and mail Linux systems provide
many other applications for performing
internet related tasks such as filezilla
xchat pigeon and others most Linux
distributions offer LibreOffice to
create and edit different kinds of
documents
Linux systems offer entire Suites of
development applications and tools
including compilers and debuggers Linux
systems offer a number of sound players
including amarok audacity and Rhythm box
Linux systems offer a number of movie
players including VLC and players Dean
and totem Linux systems offer a number
of movie editors including Kino
cinepaint blender among others
the utility is a feature-rich image
retouching and editing tool available on
all Linux distributions
other Graphics utilities that help
perform various image related tasks are
EOG inkscape convert and scrivas
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to use the command line to perform
operations in Linux
search for files
create and manage files
install and update software
Linux system administrators spend a
significant amount of their time in a
command line prompt they often automate
and troubleshoot tasks in this text
environment there's a saying graphical
user interfaces make easy tasks easier
while command line interfaces make
difficult tasks possible
Linux relies heavily on the abundance of
command line tools the command line
interface provides the following
advantages no ugui overhead is incurred
virtually any and every task can be
accomplished while sitting at the
command line
you can Implement scripts for often used
or easy to forget tasks and series of
procedures you can sign into remote
machines anywhere on the internet
you can initiate graphical applications
directly from the command line instead
of hunting through menus
while graphical tools may vary among
Linux distributions the command line
interface does not
a terminal emulator program emulates or
simulates a standalone terminal within a
window on the desktop by this we mean it
behaves essentially as if you were
logging into the machine at a pure text
terminal terminal with no running
graphical interface most terminal
emulators programs support multiple
terminal sessions by opening additional
tabs or Windows
by default on gnome desktop environments
The Gnome terminal application is used
to emulate a text mode terminal in a
window other available terminal programs
include extern console default on KDE
and Terminator
to open a terminal on any system using a
recent gnome desktop click on
applications system tools terminal or
applications utilities terminal
if you do not have the applications menu
you will have to install the appropriate
gnome shell extension package and turn
it on with gnome tweaks
on any but some of the most recent gnome
based distributions you can always open
a terminal by right-clicking anywhere on
the desktop background and selecting
open in terminal
if this does not work you will once
again need to install and activate the
appropriate gnome shell package
you can also hit alt F2 and type in
either gnome terminal or console
whichever is appropriate
because distributions have had a history
of bearing opening up a command line
terminal and the place in menus may vary
in the desktop GUI it is a good idea to
figure out how to pin the terminal icon
to the panel which might mean adding it
to the favorites grouping on gnome
systems
there are some basic command line
utilities that are used constantly and
it would be impossible to proceed
further without using some some of them
in simple forms before we discuss them
in more detail a short list has to
include cat used to type out a file or
combine files head used to show the
first few lines of a file tail used to
show the last few lines of a file man
used to view documentation
this screenshot shows Elementary uses of
these programs note the use of the pipe
symbol the vertical line you used to
have one program take as input the
output of another
for the most part we will only only use
these utilities and screenshots
displaying various activities before we
discuss them in detail
most input lines entered at the Shell
prompt have three basic elements
the command
the options and the arguments
the command is the name of the program
you are executing it may be followed by
one or more options or switches that
modify what the command may do options
usually start with one or two dashes for
example Dash p or dash dash print in
order to differentiate them from
arguments which represent what the
command operates on
however plenty of commands have no
options no arguments or neither in
addition other elements such as setting
environment variables can also appear on
the command line when launching a task
all the demonstrations created have a
user configured with pseudo capabilities
to provide the user with administrative
privileges when required
sudo allows users to run programs using
the security privileges of another user
generally root the super user on your
own systems you may need to set up
enable sudo to work correctly to do this
you need to follow some steps that will
not explain much detail now but you will
learn about later in this course
when running on Ubuntu and some other
recent distributions Sudo is already
always set up for you during
installation another Linux distributions
you will likely need to set up sudo to
work properly for you after the initial
installation
next you will learn the steps to setup
and run sudo on your system
if your system does not already have
sudo set up in and enabled you need to
do the following steps
you'll need to make modifications to the
administrative or super user root while
sudo will become the preferred method of
doing this we do not have to have it set
up yet so we use we will use Su which
we'll discuss later in detail Instead at
the command line prompt type Su and
press enter you'll then be prompted for
the root password so enter it and press
enter you'll notice that nothing is
printed this is so so others cannot see
the password on the screen you should
end up with a different looking prompt
often ending with a hash mark or a pound
sign for example Su and then password
now you need to create a configuration
file to enable your user account to use
sudo typically this file is created in
the slash Etc slash
sudoers.d slash directory with the name
of the file that as the same as your
username for example for this demo let's
say your username is student after doing
step one you would then create the
configure duration file for student by
doing this
Echo student all equals all all and then
the the directory here finally some
Linux distributions will complain if you
do not also change from missions on the
file by doing
chmod 440 and then put the file name
that should be it for the rest of this
course if you use sudo you should be
properly set up when using sudo by
default you will be prompted to give a
password your own user password at least
the the first time you do it within a
specified time interval it's possible
though very insecure to configure pseudo
to not require password or change the
time window in which the password does
not have to be repeated with every
pseudo command
the customizable nature of Linux allows
you to drop the graphical interface
temporarily or permanently or to start
it up after the system has been running
most Linux distributions give an option
during installation or have more than
one version of the install media to
choose between desktop with a graphical
desktop and server usually without one
Linux production servers are usually
installed without the GUI and even if it
is installed usually do not launch it
during the system startup removing the
graphical interface from a production
server can be very helpful in
maintaining a lean system which can be
easier to support and keep secure
VT or virtual terminals are console
sessions that use the entire display and
keyboard outside of a graphical
environment such terminals are
considered virtual because although
there can be multiple active terminals
only one terminal remains visible at a
time a VT is not quite the same as
command line terminal window you can
have many of those visible at once on a
graphical desktop
one virtual terminal usually number one
or seven is reserved for the graphical
environment and text logins are enabled
on the unused VTS Ubuntu uses vt7 but
since OS in Rel and opensuse vt1 for the
graphical display an example of a
situation where using VTS is helpful is
when you run into problems with the
graphical desktop in this situation you
can switch to one of the text VTS and
troubleshoot
to switch between VTS press Ctrl alt
function key for for the VT for example
press Ctrl alt F6 for vt6 actually you
only have to press the alt F6 key
combination if you are in a VT and want
to switch to another VT
Linux distributions can start and stop
the graphical desktop in various ways
the exact method differs from
distribution and among distribution
versions for the newer system md-based
distributions the display manager is run
as a service you can stop the GUI
desktop with the system control utility
and most distributions will also work
with the tel init command as in sudo
system control stop gdm or Studio telnet
3 and restart it after logging into the
console with sudo system control start
gdm or sudo telen 5. I'm going to move
to versions before 18.04 LTS substitute
light DM for gdm
in this section we will discuss how to
accomplish basic operations from the
command line these include how to log in
and log out from the system restart or
shut down the system locate applications
access directories identify absolute and
relative paths and explore the file
system
an available text terminal will prompt
for a username with the string login and
password when typing a password nothing
is displayed on the terminal not even a
an asterisk to indicate that you typed
in something and this is to prevent
others from seeing your password after
you've logged into the system you can
perform basic operations
once your session is started either by
logging into a text terminal or via a
graphical terminal program you can also
connect and log into remote systems by
using SSH for example by typing SSH
student at remote server.com SSH which
control it would connect securely to the
remote machine or remote server.com and
give student that's the user a command
line terminal window either using a
password as with regular logins or a
cryptographic key to sign in without
providing a password to verify the
identity
the preferred method to shut down or
reboot the system is to use the shutdown
command this sends a warning message and
then prevents further users from logging
in the init process will then control
shutting down or rebooting the system
it's important to always shut down
properly failure to do so can result in
damage to the system and or loss of data
the Halt and power off commands issue
shutdown Dash 8 to Halt the system
reboot issue shutdown Dash R and causes
the machine to reboot instead of just
shutting down both rebooting and
shutting down from the command line
requires super user or root access
when administering a multi-user system
you have the option of notifying all
users prior shutdown as in sudo
shutdown-hs 10 o'clock sitting down for
scheduled maintenance
depending on the specifics of your
particular distributions policy programs
and software packages can be installed
in various directories in general
executable programs and scripts should
live in the slash bin or slash user
slash band or slash s-pan or slash user
s spend directories or somewhere under
slash opt they can also appear in the
slash user slash local span or slash
user slash local s bin or a directory
and a user's account space such as slash
home student bin one way to locate
programs is to employ the which utility
for example to find out exactly where
the diff program resides on the file
system you can do which diff
slash user slash bin stiff if which does
not find the program where is is a good
alternative because it looks for
packages in a broader range of system
directories so where is diff
when you first log into a system or open
a terminal the default directory should
be your home directory you can prove you
can print the exact path of this by
typing Echo home mini Linux
distributions actually open new
graphical terminals in the dollar China
home desktop the following commands are
useful for directory navigation
let's get some practice navigating among
directories at the command line
so suppose I go to the temp directory CD
slash TMP I do PWD for print working
directory I'm at TMP
I could do go to the home directory by
doing CD dollar home
you see PWD now is home student
if I do CD dot dot I go up one level to
just home
another way to navigate is to use the
push D and pop D commands so I could do
push d
temp
okay and it showed me my previous
history I was at temp and I was at home
and I go to temp
now if I do pop d
it puts me back at the home directory
another thing I can do is CD Dash
and that takes me to the previous
directory just like pop D did so let's
do some basic day-to-day practices of
navigating directories that one does all
the time on a Linux system
there are two ways to identify paths
absolute path name which an absolute
path name begins with the root directory
and follows the tree branch by Branch
until it reaches the desired directory
or file absolute paths always start with
a slash or the relative path name a
relative path name starts from the
present working directory relative paths
never start with a slash multiple
slashes between directories and files
are allowed but all but one slash
between elements in the path name is
ignored by the system so if you have a
bunch of slashes it's valid but it's
just seen as just having a single slash
by the system most the time it's most
convenient to use relative paths which
require less typing usually you take
advantage of the shortcuts provided by
use dot for present directory dot dot
for Parent Directory or the utility for
your home directory for example suppose
you're currently working in your home
directory and wish to move to the slash
user slash spin directory the following
two ways will bring you to the same
directory from your home directory there
is the absolute path name method and the
relative path name method in this case
the absolute path name method requires
less typing
traversing up and down the file system
tree can get tedious the tree command is
a good way to get a bird's eye view of
the file system tree use tree Dash D
just to view just the directories and to
suppress listing the names
the following commands can help in
exploring the file system
let's get started with how to explore
the file system to access slash USR
slash local slash live from the slash
USR directory using absolute path add
command prompt type CD slash USR
slash local
slash live and press enter
go back to slash USR directory by typing
CD slash USR and press enter to access
slash USR slash local slash live from
the slash USR directory using relative
path at command prompt type CD local
slash live and press enter get to the
root directory at the command prompt
type the CD slash command
and press enter to get a list of the
files and directory in the present
working directory at the command prompt
type the ls command and press enter to
get a list of hidden files and hidden
directories at the command prompt type
the
ls-a command and press enter
to get a tree view of the file system at
the command prompt type the tree command
and press enter
to get a tree view of only directories
in the file system at the command prompt
type the treat
Dash diesel slash command and press
enter
the end utility is used to create hard
links and with the dash s option soft
links also known as symbolic links or
stem links these two kinds of links are
very useful in Unix based operating
systems suppose that file 1 already
exists a hard link called File 2 is
created with the conf with this command
note that two files now appear to exist
however a closer inspection of the file
listing shows that this is not quite
true so we'll do ls-li file 1 name File
2 and the dash I option to LS prints out
in the First Column the in node number
which is a unique quantity for each file
object this field is the same for both
these files so what is really going on
here is that there's only one file but
it has more than one name associated
with it as indicated by the two that
appears in the ls output thus there was
already another object linked to file 1
before the command was executed hard
links are very useful and they save
space but you have to be careful with
their use sometimes in subtle ways for
one thing if you remove either file 1 or
file 2 in the example the inode object
and the remaining file name will remain
which might be undesirable as it may
lead to subtle errors later if you
recreate a file of that name
if you edit one of the files exactly
what happens depends on your editor most
editors including V and G edit will
retain the link by default but it's
possible that modifying one of the names
may break the link and result in the
creation of two objects
soft or symbolic links are created with
a dash s option as in ln-s file one file
3 or ls-li 501 file three
notice file three no longer appears to
be a regular file and it clearly points
to file 1 and has a different enote
number symbolic links take notes or
space on the file system unless their
names are very long they're extremely
convenient as they can easily be
modified to point to different places an
easy way to create a shortcut from your
home directory to long path names is to
create a symbolic link unlike hard links
soft links can point to objects even on
different file systems partitions and or
disks and other media which may or may
not be currently available or even exist
in the case where the link does not
point to a currently available or
existing object you obtain a dangly link
the CD command remembers where you were
last and lets you get back there with CD
dash for remembering more than just the
last directory visited use push D to
change the directory instead of CD this
pushes your starting directory onto a
list using pop D will then send you back
to those directories walking in reverse
order the most recent directory will be
the first one retrieved with pop D the
list of directories is displayed with
the durs command
Linux provides many commands that help
you with viewing the contents of a file
creating a new file or an empty file
changing the timestamp of a file and
moving removing and renaming a file or
directory these commands help you in
managing your data and files and in and
ensuring that the correct data is
available at the correct location in
this section you will learn how to
manage files
let's get a feel for how to look at some
of the lines in a given text file on
your machine
so we have on all our Linux Foundation
virtual machines a file called ready for
DOT sh which I'm using word count
to show me it has
5127 lines
if I just want to type the whole file
out I could do that with the cat
utilities so let me just do that
but it went very very fast and in fact
if I do cat
dash n
it shows me the line numbers as it goes
and it is indeed 51.27
the way to page your way through is to
use the less utility
so then I would do less ready
4.sh
and then I get one screen at a time if I
hit the space bar I see the second
screen third screen Etc and I can keep
going all the way through the file as
fast as I want
and by the way I can also do the less
Dash capital n
option and then I also get line numbers
I did with catfishing
well similar thing
now suppose I just want to look at the
first few lines of the file I could do
head ready 4.sh
and you see that only gave me I believe
10 lines if I wanted to get 20 lines I
could just give that as an argument
okay so there we see the first 20 lines
likewise with tail
by default I get the last 10 lines if I
wanted to see the last 20 lines
I would do tail-20
and if you want to have some fun you can
use the TAC utility
where you'll notice that Tac is cat
backwards
and that just gives you the entire file
so these are day-to-day utilities one
uses just to look at the contents of
text files
touch is often used to set or update the
access change and modify times of files
by default it resets the file's
timestamp to match the current time
however you can also create an empty
file using touch like this touch and
then the file name this is normally done
to create an empty file as a placeholder
for a later purpose touch provides
several useful options for example the
dash T option allows you to set the date
and time stamp of the file to a specific
value as in touch Dash T and then we put
the value and then the file name
make there is user create directory such
as maker sampner it creates a sample
directory named sampner under the
current directory maker slash user slash
sampner will create a sample directory
called sampner under slash user
removing a directory is done with rmdir
or remove directory the directory must
be empty or the command will fail to
remove a directory and all of its
contents you have to do rm-rf
note that MV does double duty and that
it can simply rename a file or move a
file to another location while possibly
changing its name at the same time
if you're not certain about removing
files that match a pattern you supply
it's always good to run RM in
interactively RM dash dash I to prompt
before every removal
rmdir Works only at empty directories
otherwise you get an error so while
typing RM Dash RF is a fast and easy way
to remove a whole file system tree
recursively it's extremely dangerous and
should be used with the utmost care
especially when used by root recall that
recursive means drilling down through
all subdirectories all the way down a
tree
the PS1 variable is the character string
that is displayed as the prompt on the
command line most distributions set PS1
to a known default value which is
suitable in most cases however users may
want custom information shown on the
command line for example some system
administrators require the user and the
host system name to show up on the
command line as in this example
this could prove useful if you're
working in multiple roles and want to be
always reminded of who you are and what
machine you are on the prompt above
could be implemented by setting the PS1
variable to the following
for example you could do that with this
command here
by convention most systems are set up so
that the root user has a pound sign as
they're prompt
let's gained some experience with
day-to-day basic file operations on a
centos8 stream system
this would be the same on any Linux
system
so first let's create a couple of files
uh it could be empty or they could be
small one way to do it is to use the
echo command and just say Echo and the
direct actually nothing into file one
another way to do it is with the touch
command I'll say Touch file 2.
then if I do ls-a file 1 and file two
I see two very small files both created
at the same time basically
if I want to rename one of them I could
rename it with the move command like
move file one to file one
new name
and then if I do
LS shells star file star
I see there it is uh it it it has the
new name now
if I want to remove them I can simply
say RM file to
and it just work it's a good idea though
to always use the I option for
interactive when doing removal
then I would say RMI Dash I file one new
name
It'll ask me if I really want to do it
many distributions will set up the I
option to be the defaults so they always
have a chance
uh to change your mind about removing
something before you do it
now how would I make a directory I could
do Meg Deer uh dear one
in fact I can make more than one
directory on the same line I can do make
deer deer 2 and deer three
and if I look now I see I have three
different directories or all actually
empty
so let me put a couple of files in one
of the directories so I'll do Touch
deer2 file one
and I'll do touch deer to file two
so if I do ls-l-r just to see everything
that's there
in the directory files
uh that's what I'll see deer one is
empty deer two has these two files and
dear three uh is also empty
now the command for removing directories
is our end here
so let's say I just try to remove them
all with a RM dear dear star
uh you notice
it got rid of deer one and dear two but
it couldn't remove deer the deer one and
dear three I should say couldn't get rid
of deer too because there's files in it
to do that instead of using R and D or I
would say RM
RF dr2
and then that goes and descends into the
directory and gets rid of all the files
be very careful with the RN Dash RF uh
command because if you give the bad
argument you could even wipe out your
whole system but that is a standard way
to get rid of a whole directory tree
so that's just some of the very basic
commands for
renaming files moving them creating
directors removing them Etc
when commands are executed by default
there are three standard file streams or
descriptors always open for use
standard input
standard output and standard error
usually the standard input is your
keyboard and standard output and
standard error are printed on your
terminal standard error is often
redirected to an error logging file
while standard n is supplied by
directing input to come from a file or
from the output of a previous command
through a pipe standard out is also
often redirected into a file since
standard error is where error messages
are written usually nothing will go
there in Linux all open files are
represented internally by what are
called file descriptors simply put these
are represented by numbers starting at
zero standard n is file descriptor 0
standard out is file descriptor 1
standard errors file descriptor 2.
typically if other files are opened in
addition to these three which are open
by default they will start at the file
descriptor 3 and increase from there
on the next section and in the chapters
ahead you will see examples which alter
where a where a running command gets its
input where it writes its output or
where it prints diagnostic or error
messages
through the command shell we can
redirect the three standard file stream
so that we can get input from either a
file or another command instead of from
our keyboard and we can write output and
errors to files or use them to provide
input for subsequent commands
for example if we have a program called
do something that reads from standard in
and writes to standard out and standard
error we can change its input source by
using the less than sign followed by the
name of the file to be consumed for
input data here's an example
if you want to send the output to a file
use the greater than sign as in this
example
because standard error is not the same
as standard out error messages will
still will still be seen on the terminal
windows in the above example if you want
to redirect standard error to a separate
file you use standard errors file
descriptor number two the greater than
sign followed by the name of the file
you want to hold everything the running
command writes to standard error so
here's how you do that
a special shorthand notation can send
anything written to file descriptor to
standard error to the same place as file
descriptor 1. standard out you can do it
like this
bash permits an easier Syntax for the
above which is like so
the Unix Linux philosophy is to have
many simple and short programs or
commands cooperate together to produce
quite complex results rather than have
one complex program with many possible
options and modes of operation in order
to accomplish this extensive use of
pipes is made you can pipe the output of
one Commander program into another as
its input in order to do this we use the
vertical bar pipe symbol between
commands as in this example here
this represents what we often call a
pipeline and allows Linux to combine the
actions of several commands into one
this is extraordinary efficient because
Command 2 and command 3 do not have to
wait for the previous pipeline commands
to complete before they can begin
hacking at the data in their input
streams on multiple CPU or core systems
the available computing power is much
better utilized and things get done
quicker furthermore there is no need to
save output in temporary files between
the stages in the pipeline which saves
disk space and reduces reading and
writing from disk which is often the
slowest bottleneck and getting something
done
being able to quickly find the files you
are looking for will save you time and
enhance productivity you can search for
files in both your home directory space
or in any other directory or system or
or location on the system the main tools
for doing this are the locate and find
utilities we'll also show how to use
wild cards and Bash in order to specify
any file which matches a given
generalized request
the locate utility program performs a
search taking advantage of a previously
constructed database of files and
directories on your system matching all
entries that contain a specified
character string this can sometimes
result in a very long list to get a
shorter and possibly more relevant list
we can use the grep program as a filter
grep will print only the lines that
contain one or more specified string as
in this example which will list all the
files and directories with both zip and
Bin in their name we'll cover this crap
in much more detail later notice the use
of the pipe or the vertical line to pipe
the two commands together
locate utilizes a database created by a
related utility update DB most Linux
systems run this automatically once a
day however you can update it at any
time by just running update DB from the
command line as the root user let's get
some practice with locating and finding
files on an Ubuntu system
so suppose I want to find all files that
have the string lfs 300 in them so I
could do locate lfs 300.
and it finds indeed just one file that's
in the home student directory on the
subdirectory there
and I could also find it by doing find
dot meaning the current directory name
lfs 300 star
and then I'll see it finds it if I want
to find out a little more I can give the
ls option which will show me who owns it
what group they're in the length of the
file the inode the date Etc
now if I create another file
just by doing Echo into lfs 300 so it
creates essentially an empty file
the find command will find the new file
as well as the old one
but the locate command will not because
I need to update
the database that uh that the locate
command uses and I do that by running as
root so I need as you do as you do
update DB
and that was pretty quick uh and then if
I say locate it now it finds both files
okay and
um just to get rid of the file I didn't
really need I'll remove it I run update
DB again
well I need it to be root so I have to
say yes you do and then once again okay
FS 300 won't find this new file now I
can configure update dbe and locate to
do a bunch of things so if I go to the
ETC directory
you'll see there's a file called update
DB
Dot comf
and it controls where update DB does not
look where locate does not look
so for instance under prune task it says
don't look in these places like the temp
directory because they're temporary and
you don't want to keep track of what's
there particularly and prune FS these
are file systems really pseudo file
systems that are not real file systems
that you shouldn't look in because
they're also the contents change every
time you boot let's say so for instance
you don't look in the proc directory or
this is FS directory or the dev
directory uh well Dev FS directory
because these things disappear every
time you reboot
uh and so it's pretty easy to configure
some other things you can do which you
can learn by looking at the
documentation on your system
you can search for a file name
containing specific characters using
wild cards to search for files using the
question mark wildcard replace each
unknown character with question mark for
example if you know only the first two
letters are ba of a three letter file
name without an extension you can type
this
to search for files using the wildcard
replace the unknown string with the
asterisk for example if you remember
only that the extension was dot out type
LS asterisk dot out
let's get some experience using wild
cards
on an Ubuntu system so I've gone to the
VAR log directory and let me just do an
LS to see what's there so for instance
uh let me use the DU or disk usage
utility which tells me all the bytes
that are being used by a given file or
subdirectory I could do something like d
u that s uh h
uh a star
and you'll see these are all the
different things under a summer
directories like app the others are just
files if I only wanted to look at ones
which have log in the name I could do d
u this s h a star log star
and so only ones that have log in their
names
if I only want to look at the ones that
start from the letter P or later in the
alphabet I could do d u that sh
a and then I could say uh square
brackets
p through z
star you're seeing it neglected the
alternative ones uh which would have
done that
if I just want to look at uh ones which
have a certain character in them I could
do something like d u star Dot
uh one character dot star
so those are all the ones that have a
substring in them with one character
here it's always a number but it
wouldn't have to be surrounded by
periods on both sides
now you have to be careful with wild
cards that the system doesn't quote glob
what you were doing the string that
you're putting in so to give you an
example
you'll notice there's a bunch of
different files here that start with the
name VMware well they're all over in the
right column here so suppose I try to do
uh uh apt-get
install VMware star and I should make
that as you do
well it's actually looking for packages
with all these names like VMware Network
one VM VSC root 2. log and there are of
course no packages with silly names like
that but I could do something like this
now
let me put the VMware star in quotes
and you see it actually did find things
it found two packages VMware NSX common
VMware manager and it wants to install
them and it needs these other Utilities
in order for them to work uh I'm not
going to do this because I don't need
these guys so I'll just say no
so when you put something in quotes it
says don't look in the current directory
to like fill out the names to expand
what you're doing instead looking in
this case in the database packages
so you have to be careful and you'll
often see people use quotes even when
there's no need for them just to be safe
so that's a little bit of demonstration
of the use of wild cards
fine is an extremely useful and often
used utility program in the daily life
of a Linux system administrator it
recurses down the file system tree from
any particular directory or set of
directories and locates files that match
specified conditions the default path
name is always the present working
directory for example administrators
sometimes scan for potentially large
core files which contain diagnostic
information after a program fails there
are more than several weeks old in order
to remove them it's also common to
remove files that are not essential or
that are outdated in the slash TMP
directory especially those that have not
been accessed recently many Linux
distributions use shell scripts that run
periodically through cron to perform
such house cleaning
when no arguments are given find list
all files in the current directory and
all of its subdirectories commonly used
options to sort in the list include Dash
name which only lists files with a
certain pattern in their name Dash I
name also ignore the case of the file
names and dash type which will restrict
the results to files of a certain
specified type such as D for directory L
for symbolic link or F for a regular
file here's how you can search for files
and directories named GCC
here's how to search only for
directories named GCC
here's how to search for or only for
regular files named GCC
another good use of find is being able
to run commands on the files that match
your search criteria the dash exec
option is used for this purpose to find
and remove all files that end with DOT
swp you can use this
the squiggly brackets are a placeholder
that will be filled with all the file
names that result from the find
expression and the preceding command
will be run on each one individually
please note that you have to in the
command with either a semicolon
including the single quote or a slash
semicolon both forms are fine
one can also use the dash OK option
which behaves the same as Dash exec
except that find will prompt you for
permission before executing the command
this makes it a good way to test your
results before blindly executing any
potentially dangerous commands
it is sometimes the case that you wish
to find files according to attributes
such as when they were created last used
or based on their size it's easy to
perform such searches to find files
based on time you can use this
here Dash C time is when the inode
metadata or the file and ownership the
permissions last change it's often but
not necessarily when the file was first
created you can also search files based
on when they were accessed or last read
or based on when they were modified or
last written
the number is the number of days and can
be expressed in either a number in that
means exactly that Value Plus n which
means greater than the number or minus n
which means less than that number there
are similar options for times in minutes
as in the def C Min Dash amen and dash M
Min to find files based on sizes you can
do this
note that the size here is in 512 byte
blocks by default you can also specify
bytes kilobytes megabytes gigabytes Etc
as with the time numbers above file
sizes can also be exact numbers for
details consult the man page for find
for example to find files greater than
10 megabytes in size and running a
command on those files you can use this
command
let's gain some experience using a very
powerful find utility on an Ubuntu
system and I'll work in the VAR log
directory so suppose I wanted to see
every file here that's underneath our
log and let me do it as you do because
otherwise it will give me error messages
about not having permissions to look at
some files so do as you do find Dot I
get a very long list of every single
file and directory that's underneath
here if I wanted to restrict it just to
directories I would do type D
and you'll see this just shows me the
directories and subdirectories okay
because like some of them like live vert
have multiple directories if I add to
that another parameter Max
Def One
you see it suppressed the subdirectories
here I only see live bird now so I only
went down a depth of one and actually I
could do two and three or whatever is
necessary though here it doesn't go that
deep anyway now you can always add
commands to
any fine command so I could do find Dot
type
f
and then I can say exact grep Dash H log
and I put in that parentheses uh pair
there and then let's say slash
um
semicolon you can also do a single Dash
semicolon single Dash
and it searched through every single
file that had the word login and printed
out
all the different things that were there
or to keep it a little simpler I could
have done exec
just ls-l
and it would give me listings of all
these files okay
now there actually is a LS option
built into fine so I didn't really have
to do that and it will just show me that
kind of information there's other things
I can do like find
size zero
it's finding all the files I should have
done as you do but all the files that
have the size of zero and if I want to
verify that I'll add the ls option
you see these are all files of the name
with size 0. you can also do things like
find let's say I want to find everything
that's newer than this file B temp here
I could do something like this you do
find
dot newer
B temp
and it showed me everything that's been
done since then
there's a million options to find it can
be used on a lot of complicated ways you
can negate any parameter you want to put
in by saying not you can combine uh
different search criteria and I
recommend heavily that you really read
up on find if you're going to use it
because it's a little hard to describe
in a few seconds but there's a million
things you can do with it
the core parts of a Linux distribution
and most of its add-on software are
installed via the package management
system each package contains the files
and other instructions needed to make
one software component work well and
cooperate with the other components that
comprise the entire system packages can
depend on each other for example a
package for a web-based application
written in PHP can depend on the PHP
packets there are two broad families of
packages package managers those based on
Debian and those which use RPM as their
low-level package manager the two
systems are incompatible but broadly
speaking provide the same features and
satisfy the same needs there are some
other systems used by more specialized
Linux distributions in this section you
will learn how to install remove or
search for packages from the command
line using these two package Management
Systems
both package Management Systems operate
on two distinct levels a low level tool
such as dpkg or RPM takes care of the
details of unpacking individual packages
running scripts getting the software
installed correctly while a high level
tool such as apt-get dnf yum or zipper
works with groups of packages downloads
packages from the vendor and figures out
dependencies
most of the time users need to work only
with the high level tool which will take
care of calling the low level tool as
needed dependency resolution is a
particularly important feature of the
high level tool as it handles the
details of finding and installing each
dependency for you be careful however as
installing a single package could result
in many dozens or even hundreds of
dependent packages being installed
the advanced patching tool apt is the
underlying package management system
that manages software on Deviant based
systems while it forms the back end for
graphical package managers such as the
Ubuntu software Center and synaptic its
native user interface is at the command
line with programs that include apt or
apkit and app cache dnf is the open
source command line package management
utility for the RPM compatible Linux
systems that belongs to the red hat
family dnf has both command line and
graphical user interfaces Fedora and
rel8 replaced the older yam utility with
dnf thereby eliminating a lot of
historical baggage as well as
introducing many nice new capabilities
dnf is pretty much backwards compatible
with yum for day-to-day commands
zipper is the package management system
for the Susie or open Susie family and
it's also based on RPM zipper also
allows you to manage repositories from
the command line zipper is fairly
straightforward to use and resembles dnf
or yum quite closely to learn the basic
package commands take a look at these
basic packaging commands
let's get some practice with the basic
low-level command for the Debian
packaging system
dpkg or
D package so to get a list of all the
packages on the system I can simply type
dpkg dash dash list
and I'll just pipe that into the list
because it's a long list
okay
actually if I don't use less for some
reason it's more compact
okay so there are a lot of different
packages on the system
now if I want to see some information
just about a particular package I could
just
grip let's say bzip two to see what's
going on would be zip2
and that's the information about bzip2
that tells us the version number the
architecture which here is AMD 64 and
its description is a high quality block
sorting file compressor utility so it's
a more advanced program with better
compression than gzip or the
old-fashioned zip program
if I want to see what's actually
contained in that package I can do DP kg
list files and then the name of it
and then I'll go slower by putting it
into less
and you'll see there's the executables
in the bin directory and then what's
under user is basically documentation
under user share doc user sure man
Etc
if I try to remove the package let's see
what happens
so do as you do d p k g of course have
to have root privilege to remove the
package
so I'm removing these zip2d package
remove B sub 2.
and it's telling me I cannot do this
because
I need the developer and package
dpkg-st Dev that would be headers and
stuff for programs which use this in a
library version and firewaller which is
a archive extractor that's common on
Linux systems so I would have to remove
all three of them we'll see later when
we use tools like app dead it's easier
to deal with these dependencies
we'll now get some practice using the
low level RPM command in order to look
at a package try to remove itself
so we're going to type
rpm-qa for query and look at all
packages on the system and then we're
going to grip to look for the package B
zip2
okay and you see there's actually two
RPM packages which have B zip2 in their
names the actual bzip 2 program and then
bzip two lives which is libraries that
depend on bzip2
so
let's take a look more at information
about B sub 2 if I do RPM
if I do RPM there's Q for query I for
information
and then L for a list of files and
that's a lot so I'll pipe it through
less
oops I forgot to give the name in the
package so B zip2
you see the name is B zip2 you see it's
version 1.06
um we see it's
Source RPM here we see when it was
released in November 2015 out of
centos.org
and then a description of what it does
these are freely available patent free
high quality data compressor Etc
I'm going to list of the files that are
part of bzip2
if I want to get a little bit more
detailed look at what's
in there I could do something a little
fancier like RPM that Q L B zip2 we just
list the files
and then I'll make that a show command
and substitute for it and do an ls-lf on
that
so this will give me a detailed listing
and then I'll pipe it into less
and these are the actual files that are
in the package and a little bit more
detail like their length and what type
of files you'll notice for instance B
unzip two and B zip2 are really the same
file it's just a symbolic link
and the system knows what to do or I
should say the application knows what to
do whether the zipper unzip depending on
how it's called
now let's see what happens if I try to
remove the package
so I I would should be uh rude to do
that so do an S you do
and then I'll do RPM Dash e for a race
and then just to be extra careful I'll
use the dash there's test which means it
won't actually do anything with this
option it'll just see if it could do it
bzip two so I try to remove it
and it's telling me that I can't do that
because it's needed by those following
three packages as well as the file
roller program which is an archiving
program present on basically all Linux
distributions
and then I can get a little more
information in a different way with
rpm-q dash dash what
provides B zip2
and you'll see it's the B zip2 package
and if I do what requires
I get the same information about the
three packages that would like that
need to have bzip2 installed for them to
behave properly and not crash or
anything
a little bit later we're going to
discuss yum and zipper and also dnf
which are higher level programs that can
handle dependencies in robust fashion
RPM is really designed for individual
packages which
are listed on the command line or groups
of packages listed on the command line
let's get some practice using dnf from
the command line on a recent Fedora
system
so in order to do that first I'll have
to bring up the command line so I'll do
that with activities and I'll click on
the terminal icon at the bottom and I've
got a nice command line terminal and
I'll make it a little bit bigger because
the the font's bigger that is because
it's hard to see with the smaller fonts
and then first let's get a list of all
packages
that have the string bzip two in their
name
so I'll do that with dnf list
and the first package is that will come
up will be the ones that are already
installed so let me scroll up a little
because there's a really long list here
so there I have the actual program bc2 a
development package in case I want to
write code that uses bzip2 in internally
and then uh bzip two lives would be used
by programs that have been zip2 and
already built into them
the two I'm going to be interested in
installing here are the lbzip tube
packages
lbzip 2 is a parallel version of B sub 2
that can separate the amount of work
into a number of pieces that can be done
simultaneously so for instance if you
had four processors or cores you could
split the work up into four pieces and
do them all at the same time and then
merge them at the end and in theory it
could run almost four times as quickly
so let's try to install the utilities
package I do as you do dnf install
live bzip two
yeah I guess it's lb is it two B zip two
utils
and you'll see yes it's happy to do that
but it also needs the lbzip 2 package
which it depends on so say yes I'll just
type y
and it will install the two packages
um I probably have a program now called
lbzip2 but let's check if that's the
case
with which
and yes I do
so I could go ahead and use it now if I
wanted
if I don't really want these installed
and I want to clean up with them I could
do uh something like yes you do dnf
remove lb zip2
and you notice it's happy to remove it
but it's telling me that because lbzip 2
utils depends on lbzip two if I remove
lb zip2 I better remove them both
otherwise I'll have an unsatisfied
dependency so I'll just say yes
so that's just a really simple uh
example of using dnf in the command line
unfortunately recent red hat-based
systems do not have a really good
graphical package management utility
Fedora has something called dnf Dragon
but it can be rather slow to load and a
little bit buggy and there's nothing at
all for Red Hat Aid or Central S8 so
experienced developers will just always
tend to do things from the command line
let's demonstrate some basic package
managing functions on an open Souza
system using the zipper utility so first
let's look for all
packages with zipper
search that have the string new cloth in
them
and we see a number of packages let's
concentrate on the documentation package
so suppose I try to install that and for
that I have to be a super user for an
installation so I do as you do zipper
install new plot Dot
and you notice it's telling me I not
only have to install new plot.talk I
would have to install new plot which is
the actual program that new plot.doc
their stock documents so I'll say sure
yes
and it's been done successfully if I
want to get some information about
the package I can do rpm-qi
new clot their stock and for this once
again I do not have to be root
and it's telling me the name the version
the size all sorts of things and under
the purposes telling me it concludes the
man and the info Pages for this rather
useful plotting program
now suppose I want to remove this
package I can do zipper
remove the new
plot let's say I try to remove the new
plot not not new plot.
and it's telling me that if I am remove
new plot I also have to remove new plot.
because otherwise there would be unmet
dependencies so say yes for sure
and now both of them are gone so that's
basic steps you would take to look for a
package install it get some information
about it and remove it using zipper
so let's do some basic package
management
on an Ubuntu system using Debian
Packaging
we're going to use the high level
utilities which understand dependencies
at Cash cannot get
so first let's look for
all packages
that contain the string
that you get two so we do that with app
cache search wget2
and it comes up with wget 2 and wget to
Dev
this is uh an enhancement to the
standard wget utility which is used for
recursive downloading of the content of
a website or some other kinds of
resources
so let's just try and install so the as
you do at get install wget to dash Dev
and it's telling me it also needs to
install W live W get 0 and wget 2. it
shouldn't be that surprising that you
need to install the base packages on
which the development packages built up
and it will download 264 kilobytes of
archives but once everything's installed
it will expand out to 805 kilobytes so
let's just say yes I'll type y
and it quickly goes ahead and does all
that
now suppose I want to remove
wget to devil more interesting let's try
to remove
wget
uh itself
so what is it doing
well I shouldn't have removed W again I
meant W get two w again I do not want to
remove so I'll type it again with the
two
and you see it wants to remove wget
to Dev as well because without wget wget
to Dev isn't have much meaning okay and
we no longer need the live W get zero
um it's sort of orphaned out but we'll
leave it there for now so I'll just say
yes
and I have removed things from my system
so that's the most basic operations you
would need to do on an Ubuntu system
using Debian Packaging
you have completed chapter seven let's
summarize the key Concepts we covered
virtual terminals or VT and Linux are
consoles or command line terminals that
use the connected Monitor and keyboard
different Linux distributions start and
stop the graphical desktop in different
ways a terminal emulator program on the
graphical desktop works by emulating a
terminal within a window on the desktop
the Linux system allows you to either
log in via text terminal or remotely via
the console when typing your password
nothing is printed to the terminal not
even a generic symbol to indicate that
you typed
the preferred method to shut down or
reboot the system is to use the shutdown
command
there are two types of path names
absolute and relative
an absolute path name begins with the
root directory and follows the tree
branch by Branch until it reaches the
desired directory or file
a relative path name starts with the
present working directory using hard and
soft symbolic links is extremely useful
in Linux
CD remembers where you were last and
lets you get back there with CD Dash
locate performs a database search to
find all file names that match a given
pattern
find locates files recursively from a
given directory or set of directories
find is able to run commands on the
files that it lists when used with the
dash X exec options
touch is used to set the access change
and edit time to files as well as to
create empty files the advanced package
tool packaging tool apt this package
management system is used to manage
installed software on dbm based sus
systems you can use the dnf command line
package development utility for the RPM
based Red Hat Family Linux distributions
the zipper package management system is
based on RPM and used for open Susie
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to use different sources of
documentation
use the Man pages
access the new info system use the help
command and the dash dash help option
use other documentation sources
whether you are an inexperienced user or
a veteran you'll not always know or
remember the proper use of various Linux
programs and utilities what is the
command to type what options does it
take Etc you'll need to consult help
documentation regularly because Linux
based systems draw from a large variety
of sources there are numerous reservoirs
of documentation and ways of getting
help Distributors consolidate this
material and present it in a
comprehensive and easy to use manner
important Linux documentation sources
include the Man pages short for manual
pages new info
the help command and dash def's help
option
other documentation sources like the Gen
2 handbook
The Man pages are the most often used
source of Linux documentation they
provide in-depth documentation about
many programs and utilities as well as
other topics including configuration
files and programming apis for system
calls library library routines and the
kernel they are present on all Linux
distributions and are always at your
fingertips
The Man pages infrastructure was first
introduced in the early Unix versions in
the beginning of the 1970s the name man
is just an abbreviation for manual
typing man with a topic name as an
argument retrieves the information
stored in the Topic's Man pages the man
program searches formats and displays
the information contained in the man
page system because many topics have
copious amounts of relevant information
output is piped through a pager program
such as less to be viewed one page at a
time at the same time the information is
formatted for a good visual display a
given topic may have multiple Man pages
associated with it and there is a
default order determining which one is
displayed when no options or section
number is specified to list all pages on
the topic use the dash F option to list
all pages that discuss a specific topic
even if the specified topic is not
present in the name use the dash dash K
option
let's use the man utility to get some
information about sockets on our system
I just type man socket
I get chapter two
of the Linux programmers manual
I get the page in there in chapter two
that has to do with sockets and this is
a pretty General page that tells me a
lot of information about sockets and
different protocols that they can use
if I want to get a list of all the pages
that occult socket I do man Dash fsocket
you see there's actually five of them in
different chapters
that by the way is exactly the same as
saying what is socket
so man Dash F and apropower are the same
if I want to see a particular page say
chapter seven I can do nand seven
socket
and I'm getting the man page in chapter
seven
which is rather detailed if I want to
see them all at once I can say Man dash
a socket for all I guess
and I can space my way through this one
if I hit Q
it's telling me if I hit return I'll see
the next one 3p so let's do that
I'll hit Q again you see if I want to
get out rather than going through the
rest of them the next one would be seven
I can hit Ctrl C Ctrl D would just skip
the next one
if I want to see all Man pages that have
the word socket in there this basic
description
I do that with Man dash k
that's arrived a long list because
sockets are pretty basic and involve all
sorts of things on your system Man dash
K is exactly the same
just typing apropos socket
and I get the exact same thing
so that's just some basic day-to-day
functioning of using man to get
information you should play around with
different Man pages and look at the real
contents in them and see how they differ
from page to page
the next source of Linux documentation
is the new info system this is the new
project standard documentation format
which it prefers as an alternative to
man the info system is basically
freeform and supports linked subsections
functionally info resembles man in many
ways however topics are connected using
links even though its design predates
the World Wide Web information can be
viewed through either a command line
interface a graphical help utility
printed or viewed online typing info
with no arguments in a terminal window
displays an index of available topics
you can browse through the topic list
using the regular movement Keys arrows
page up and page down you can view help
for a particular topic by typing info
topic name the system then searches for
the topic in all available info files
some useful keys are queue to quit is
for help and enter to select a menu item
the topic which you view and then info
page is called a node this table lists
the basic keystrokes for moving between
nodes nodes are essentially sections and
subsections in the documentation you can
move between nodes or view each node
sequentially each node may contain menus
and links subtopics or items items
function like browser links and are
identified by an asterisk at the
beginning of the item name named items
outside menu are identified with double
colons at the end of the item name items
can refer to other nodes within the file
or to other files
let's gain some experience using the
info command for documentation
so suppose I type info make I will get
information about the make you utility
used by all programmers
and this takes me to the top of the info
page or the head node if I want to look
for a particular topic I can hit slash
and you'll see at the bottom it's
prompting me for assert so I'll say
example
and it brought me down here to rule
if I just hit return
I get that page now at the top you'll
notice
it says the node is root example the
next one is Rule syntax so if I hit an n
I get the rule syntax it says the next
one is prerequisite types if I hit and
again I get prerequisite types
if I hit P I will go back to the
previous one so I hit B rule syntax
if I want to look again for example
I can just hit the slash again and it's
it's prompting me for the same string so
I'll just hit return
and I'm finding a later example about
wild card examples and if I hit return I
find out above that if I want to go all
the way up I can hit a u
it takes me to the top of section 4.4
I hit U again I'm at chapter four
I hit you again I'm at the very top of
everything
so I want to get information on the
various keystroke bindings I can hit an
H for help
and you'll see in the bottom window
where the focus is shifted to it lists
all the possible keystrokes and what
they can do
so that's basically how I would use info
if I hit Q I am out of it and the rest
you can learn by navigating within the
info page of any topic that interests
you
another important source of Linux
documentation is the use of the dash
dash help option most commands have an
available short description which can be
viewed using the dash dash help or the
dash H option along with the command or
application for example to learn more
about the man command you can type man
def Dash help the dash help option is
useful as a quick reference and it
displays information faster than the man
or info pages
when running within a bash command shell
some popular commands such as Echo and
CD actually run especially built-in bass
versions of the commands rather than the
usual binaries found on the file system
it's more efficient to do so as
execution is faster because fewer
resources are used one should note that
there can be some usually small
differences in the two versions of the
command to view a synopsis of these
built-in commands you can simply type
help as shown in this screenshot
for these built-in commands help
performs the same basic function as the
dash H and dash dash help arguments
perform for Standalone programs
in addition to the Man pages the new
info system and the help command there
are other sources of Linux documentation
some of the some examples of which
include desktop help system package
documentation and online resources
you have completed chapter 8. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered the
main sources of Linux documentation are
the Man pages new info and the help
options and commands and a rich variety
of online documentation sources
the man utility searches formats and
displays Man pages The Man pages provide
in-depth documentation about programs
and other topics about the system
including configuration files system
calls Library routines and the kernel
the new info system was created by the
new project as a as its standard
documentation it's robust and it's
accessible via command line web and
graphical tools
short descriptions for commands are
usually displayed with the dash 8 or
dash dash help argument you can type
help at the command line to display a
synopsis of built-in commands there are
many other help resources both on your
system and on the internet
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to describe what a process is and
distinguish between types of processes
enumerate process attributes
manage processes using PS and top
understand the use of load averages and
other process metrics manipulate
processes by putting them in background
and restoring them to foreground
use at cron and sleep to schedule
processes in the future or pause them
a process is simply an instance of one
or more related tasks threads executing
on your computer it's not the same as a
program or a command a single command
may actually start several processes
simultaneously some processes are
independent of each other and others are
related a failure of one process may or
may not affect the others running on
this on the system processes use mini
system resources such as memory CPU
cycles and peripheral devices such as
network cards hard drives printers and
displays the operating system especially
the kernel is responsible for allocating
a proper share of these resources to
each process and ensuring overall
optimized system utilization
a terminal window one kind of command
shell is a process that runs as long as
needed it allows users to execute
programs and access resources in an
interactive environment you can also run
programs in the background which means
they become detached from the shell
processes can be of different types
according to the task being performed
here's some different process types
along with their description
descriptions and examples
a critical kernel function called the
scheduler consistently shifts processes
on and off the CPU sharing time
according to the relative priority how
much time is needed and how much has
already been granted to a task when a
process is in a so-called running state
it means it's either currently executing
instructions on a CPU or it's waiting to
be granted a share of time a Time slice
so it can execute all processes in this
state reside on what is called a run
queue and on a computer with multiple
CPUs or cores there there's a run cue on
each CPU or core however sometimes
processes go into what is called a sleep
State generally when they're waiting for
something to happen before they can
resume perhaps for the user to type
something in this condition a process is
said to be sitting in a weight queue
there are some other less free process
States especially when a process is
terminating sometimes a child process
completes but its parent process has not
asked about its state amusingly such a
process is said to be called a said to
be in a zombie State it's not really
alive but still shows up in the system's
list of processes
at any given time there are always
multiple processes being executed the
operating system keeps track of them by
assigning each of each a unique process
ID or PID number the PID is used to
track process State CPU usage memory use
precisely where resources are located in
memory and other characteristics new
pids are usually assigned in ascending
order as processes are born thus pid1
denotes the init process and and
succeeding processes are gradually
assigned higher numbers
the table explains the PID types and
their descriptions
at some point one of your applications
may stop working properly how do you
eliminate it
to terminate a process you can type kill
Dash Sig kill PID or kill-9 the PID no
however you can only kill your own
processes those belonging to another
user are off limits unless you're root
many users can access a system
simultaneously and each user can run
multiple processes the operating system
identifies a user who starts the process
by the real user ID or the ruid assigned
to the user the user who determines the
access rights for the users is
identified by the effective uid the euid
the EU ID may or may not be the same as
the ruid users can be categorized into
various groups each group is identified
by the real group ID or the rgid the
access rights of the group are
determined by the effective group ID the
EG ID each user can be a member of one
or more groups most of the time we
ignore these details and just talk about
the user ID the uid and the group ID GID
at any given time many processes are
running on the system however a CPU can
actually accommodate only one task at a
time just like a car can have only one
driver at a time some processes are more
important than others so Linux allows
you to set and manipulate process
priority higher priority processes get
preferential access to the CPU the
priority for a process can be set by
specifying a nice value or niceness for
the process for the the lower the nice
value the higher the priority low values
are assigned to important processes
while high values are assigned to
processes that can wait longer a process
with a high nice value simply allows
other processes to be executed first in
Linux a nice value of negative 20
represents the highest priority and
positive 19 represents the lowest well
this may sound backwards this convention
goes back to the earliest days of Unix
you can also sign a so-called real-time
priority to time sensitive tasks such as
controlling machines through a computer
or collecting incoming data
a very high priority and is not to be
confused with what is called hard real
time which is conceptually different and
has more to do with making sure a job
gets completed within a very
well-defined time window
so now let's show
how to see what the niceness or priority
of our process is and how you can change
it with the renice command or how you
can do it actually from a graphical user
interface
so let's look at the processes in this
current screen with the PS command which
we will discuss in detail later and we
see that this current bash shell is 30
77. to see the priority I can run PS
with the options LF
and there you see 3077 here
is is uh here is the bash command
and the license is zero so let's try to
change the license I can do re nice
um plus 5 30 77
and you see it did change the priority
to five which I can see once again with
the PS command it has made it five here
notice that the child processor ran off
during the command pslf also has a nice
sense of five
is there anything else I create in this
shell will have that new niceness
so this is a lower priority remember
increasing the nicest lower to priority
so now suppose I try to increase their
priority by decreasing the nicest to -5
you notice it says I can't do that
that's because only the super user or
root is allowed to increase the priority
of a process
but if I type the same command over
again with s you do
it worked just fine and I can verify
that once again with pslf
and there you see it's set up to be
minus five now as well as the new
um
the new uh PS command that I issued now
if I want to do this from a graphical
utility I can run gnome system monitor
I'll start from the command line here
though I could get it from a menu
and uh this is on the first possible
screen here on processes
so if I hear that was process 30
that was process 3077 it's right here
and you notice it says priority High
I could right click on there and I can
go to change priority
and I can just say low
and now you see that it's low
and if I get out of the graphical
utility and I look at the niceness again
you see now the priority has come up to
five
I'm not the niceness of five so that
means it's a little priority again
so that's how you can manipulate the
priority of a process from the command
line or from a graphical utility
the load average is the average of the
load number for a given period of time
it takes into account processes that are
actively running on a CPU considered
runnable but waiting for a CPU to become
available or sleeping I.E waiting for
some kind of resource to become
available the load average can be viewed
by running W top or uptime the load
average is displayed using three numbers
such as 0.45 0.17 and 0.12 in this
screenshot assuming our system is a
single CPU system the three load average
numbers are interpreted as follows
0.45 means for the last minute the
system has been 45 utilized on average
0.17 means for the last five minutes
utilization has been 17 and 0.12 is for
the last 15 minutes utilization has been
12 percent if we saw a value of 1 in the
second position that would imply the
single CPU system was 100 util lies on
average over the past five minutes this
is good if we want to fully use a system
value over one for a single CPU system
implies that the system was over
utilized there were more processes
needing CPU than CPU was available if we
had more than one CPU say a quad CPU
system we would divide the load average
numbers by the number of CPUs in this
case for example seeing a one minute
load average of 4.0 implies that the
system as a whole was one hundred
percent four divided by four utilized
during the last minute
short-term increases are usually not a
problem a high peak you see is likely a
burst of activity not a new level for
example at startup mini processes start
and then act and then activities to
settles down the high peak is seen in
the 5 and 15 minute load averages it may
be cause for concern
Linux supports background and foreground
job processing a job in this context is
just a command launched from a terminal
window foreground jobs run directly from
the shell and when one foreground job is
running other jobs need to wait for
Shell access at least in that terminal
window if using the GUI until it's
completed this is fine when jobs
complete quickly but this can have an
adverse effect if the current job is
going to take a long time even several
hours to complete in such cases you can
run the job in the background and free
the shell for other tasks the background
job will be executed at lower priority
which in turn will allow smooth
execution of the interactive tasks and
you can type other commands in the
terminal window while the background job
is running by default all jobs are
executed in the foreground you can put a
job in the background by suffixing and
or the Amber stand to the command for
example update DB ampersand and you can
either use Ctrl Z to suspend a
foreground job or control C to terminate
a foregun job and you can always use the
BG and FG commands to run a process in
the background and foreground
respectively
the job utility displays all jobs
running in the background the display
shows the job ID State and command name
as shown here jobs L provides the same
information as jobs and adds the PID of
the background jobs
the background jobs are connected to the
terminal window so if you log off the
jobs utility will not show the one
started from that window
PS provides information about currently
running processes keyed by pid if you
want a repetitive update of this status
you can use top or other commonly
installed variants such as h-top or atop
from the command line or invoke your
distributions graphical system monitor
application PS has many options for
specifying exactly which tasks to
examine what information to display
about them and precisely what output
format should be used without options PS
will display all processes running under
the current shell you can use the dash U
option to display information of
processes for a specified username the
command ps-ef displays all the processes
in the system in full detail the command
ps-elf goes one step further and
displays one line of information for
every thread remember a process can
contain multiple threads
PS has another style of option
specification which stems from the BSD
variety of Unix where options are
specified without preceding dashes for
example the command PS aux displays all
processes of all users the command PS
EXO allows you to specify which
attributes you want to view
this screenshot shows a sample output of
PS with the aux and axo qualifiers
the PS utility is used very often at the
command line to gather information about
what is running on the system about the
various processes and tasks which are
running what resource they were using
what relationship they have to each
other Etc
if I just type PS without any arguments
I get the processes which have been
launched underneath this particular
terminal window and in order to make it
more interesting I have a background
processes running I have a cat an
orderless which is the file manager and
the events which is the PDF viewer and
get more information if I type ps-f
which you see now also tells me that
parent process ID
so you notice bash as a process like Z
of 2942 and that's the parent process
for both the cat and the Nautilus which
I launched directly out of the shell as
well as the PS command itself
uh the events
command is actually has something else
is apparent for complicated reasons
having to do with how the gnome shell
runs if I want to get a different piece
of information I can do ps-l
and now uh I'm also seeing information
in these two columns about the priority
and the niceness which on most Linux
systems is just a a numerical shift okay
from a neutral niceness of zero means
the default priority of 80 which is what
all normal processes start out with
now I can do more than this if I want to
give additional arguments so I do PS
there's elf
this will tell me about all processes on
the system and let me type it into less
so it doesn't go too quickly
so you can see this is everything which
is actually running on my system
you'll notice that the first bunch of
processes in this rather long list all
have these square brackets around them
that means they were not started by a
user program they're running inside the
kernel to do various kinds of background
tasks that run in the kernel all the
time handle moving things from one CPU
to another for instance and all kinds of
other things
uh and you see they have different
priorities uh they the minus 20 here uh
minus 20 there that means they're higher
priorities okay it's kind of backwards
the lower the priority number here the
higher the priorities
if I page down to the bottom I will
eventually get to the tests which are
not running inside the kernel which are
uh running for instance uh under my name
here Coop as you see these are the
actual user processes and they they're
quite a bit different
now one reason the PS command can be a
little confusing is that there are
different kinds of options those which
have a dash in which those which do not
so for instance P Ash Dash e is
different than PS space e one commonly
set of options is psaux without a dot
dash
and there you see uh one nice additional
piece of information is the percentage
of CPU being used and of course there
isn't much going on in the system right
now so that tends to be zero
so you can customize what the output of
the PS command is uh if you look at the
man page for PS you'll see there's ways
to have it print out only the columns
that you want if you want to produce
some customized reports Etc but a
standard Linux system administrator
probably uses PS every day for one thing
or another
Street displays the processes running on
the system in the form of a tree diagram
showing the relationship between a
process and its parent process and any
other processes that it created repeated
entries of that process are not
displayed and threads are displayed in
curly braces
while a static view of what the system
is doing is useful monitoring the system
performance live over time is also
valuable one option would be to run PS
at regular intervals say every few
seconds a better alternative is to use
top to get constant real-time updates
until you exit by typing q.top this
clearly highlights which processes are
consuming the most CPU cycles and memory
using appropriate commands from within
top the first line of the top output
displays a quick summary of what is
happening in the system including how
long the system has been up how many
users are logged on and what is the load
average the load average determines how
busy the system is load average of 1.00
per CPU indicates a fully subscribed but
not overloaded system if the load
average goes above the value and it
indicates that the processors are
competing for CPU time if the load
average is very high it might indicate
that the system is having a problem such
as a runaway process a process and a
non-responding state the second line of
the top output displays the total number
of processes the number of running
sleeping stopped and zombie processes
comparing the number of running
processes with the load average helps
determine if the system has reached its
capacity or perhaps a particular user is
running too many processes the stopped
processes should be examined to see if
everything is running correctly the
third line of the top output indicates
how the CPU time is being divided
between the users and the kernel by
displaying the percentage of cputine
used for each the percentage of user
jobs running at a lower priority
niceness Dash ni is then listed idle
mode or ID should be low if the load
average is high and and vice versa the
percentage of jobs waiting wa for Io is
listed interrupts include the percentage
of Hardware or hi versus software
interrupts SI steel time St is generally
used with virtual machines which has
some of its idle CPU time taken for
other uses
the fourth and fifth lines of the top
output indicate memory usage which is
divided into categories
physical memory or Ram displayed on line
4 and swap space displayed on line 5.
both categories display total memory
used memory and free space
you need to monitor memory usage very
carefully to ensure good system
performance once the physical memory is
exhausted the system starts using swap
space or temporary storage space on the
hard drive as an extended memory pool
and since accessing disk is much slower
than access accessing memory this will
negatively affect the system performance
if the system starts using swap often
you can add more swap space however
adding more physical memory should also
be considered each line in the process
list of the top output displays
information about a process by default
processes are ordered by highest CPU
usage the following information about
each process is displayed process
identification number PID process owner
the user priority PR and nice values ni
virtual physical and shared memory
status that's a percentage of CPU and
memory used execution time the time plus
and command besides reporting
information top can be utilized
interactively for monitoring and
controlling processes well top is
running in a terminal window you can
enter single letter commands to change
its behavior for example you can view
the top ranked processes based on CPU or
memory usage if needed you can alter the
priorities of running processes or you
can stop or kill a process this table
lists what happens when pressing various
Keys when running top
the top utility is used to interactively
monitor what processes and tests are
doing on your system to start it up all
you have to do is type top
and it will refresh itself at some
interval of a I think by default two or
three seconds it's easily changed it
shows you standard information about
each process similar to what you get
with the PS command such as the process
ID the user the priority and niceness
some information about how the memory is
being used by the process the state SB
meaning sleeping for instance and by
default it is sorted by CPU time and
then there's also memory the total time
and what the actual command is
the lines at the top or or have been
designed over the years to convey a lot
of information so in the first one you
see how long the system has been up how
many users there are the low to average
or rolling averages of how much time has
been spent in the last I believe one
minute five minutes Etc there are
currently 295 tests running on the
system but really only one is running
the others are sleeping
um and this shows you the CPU time
percentage is used by the user processes
by the system by so-called nice
processes
and then idle
and how many would be waiting how many
are high priority and and some other
details like that and then you have
basic information about the memory such
how much is being used how much swap
there's available being used how much is
in cash Etc if I type the letter one I
get statistics for each CPU instead of
uh just The Amalgamated total and that
can be rather useful one will take it
back again if I hit H I get a listing of
what the possible keys I can hit are and
what they do would make sense to try to
run through much of that here but I
highly recommend that you run top and
play with these different keys and try
to understand what kind of information
you can extract
well top is how you can do it from the
command line and if you hit q that will
kill the program you can get some
information by going to your menus and
finding system monitor
and then uh let me drag that over to
this screen
uh the processes pane on here is pretty
much the same as tops get the same
information it's easier to do things
like restore because I could just click
on memory and get it sorted by how much
memory is used if I click again I'll get
it in descending order
uh priorities CPU Etc you can also once
again change the priority of processes
you can kill them
Etc so you can do a lot if you want to
see the graph just click on resources
you can see what's going with the
constantly redrawn graph and with file
systems you can see
how much of your file systems on the
computer are actually full where they're
mounted Etc so that's a brief
explanation of top and some related
issues
suppose you need to perform a task on a
specific day sometime in the future
however you know you will be away from
the machine on that day how will you
perform the task you can use the at
utility program to execute any
non-interactive command at a specified
time as Illustrated in this screenshot
KRON is a time-based scheduling utility
program it can launch routine background
jobs at specific times and or days on an
ongoing basis cron is driven by a
configuration file
called the cron table which contains the
various shell commands that need to be
run at the properly scheduled times they
are both system-wide cront tab files and
individual user-based ones each line of
the cront tab file represents a job and
is composed of a so-called cron
expression followed by a shell command
to execute typing cront tab e will open
the cront tab Editor to edit existing
jobs or to create new jobs each line of
the cront tab file will contain six
fields
and here are some examples
sometimes a command or job must be
delayed or suspended suppose for example
an application has read the and
processed the contents of a data file
and then needs to save a report on a
backup system if the backup system is
currently busy or not available the
application can be made to sleep or wait
until it can complete its work such a
delay might might be to mount the backup
device and prepare it for writing
sleep suspends execution for at least
the specified period of time which can
be given as the number of seconds the
default minutes hours or days after that
time has passed or an interrupting
signal has been received execution will
resume the syntax is sleep and the
number and then the suffix where the
suffix may be S for seconds the default
M for minutes H for hours or D for days
sleep and at or at are quite different
sleep delays execution for a specific
period Well at starts execution at a
later time
you have completed chapter nine let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
processes are used to perform various
tasks on the system processes can be
single threaded or multi-threaded
processes can be of different types such
as interactive and non-interactive every
process has a unique identifier the PID
to enable the operating system to keep
track of it the nice value or niceness
can be used to set priority PS provides
information about the currently running
processes you can use top to get
constant real-time updates about overall
system performance as well as
information about the processes running
on the system
load average indicates the amount of
utilization the system is under at
particular times
Linux supports background and foreground
processing for a job
at executes any non-interactive command
at a specified time
KRON is used to schedule tasks that need
to be performed at regular intervals
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to explore the file system and its
hierarchy explain the file system
architecture compare files and identify
different file types
and back up and compressed data
in Linux and all unix-like operating
systems it is often said everything is a
file or at least at least it's treated
as such this means whenever you are
dealing with normal data files and
documents or with devices such as sound
cards and printers you interact with
them through the same kind of input
output operations this simplifies things
you open a file and perform normal
operations like reading the file and
writing on it which is one reason why
text editors which you will learn about
in an upcoming section are so important
on many systems including Linux the file
system is structured like a tree the
tree is usually portrayed as inverted
and starts at what is most often called
the root directory which marks the
beginning of the hierarchical file
system and is also sometimes referred to
as the trunk or simply denoted by a
slash the root directory is not the same
as the root user the hierarchical file
system all also contains other elements
in the path or directory names which are
separated by forward slashes as in user
slash spin slash emacs where the last
element is the actual file name in this
section you will learn about some basic
concepts including the file system
hierarchy as well as about disk
partitions
Linux supports a number of native file
system types expressly created by Linux
developers such as ext3 exe4 squash fs
and BT RFS it also offers
implementations of file systems used on
other alien operating systems such as
those from Windows SGI IBM or Mac OS
many older Legacy file systems such as
fat are also supported
each file system on a Linux system
occupies a disk partition partitions
help to organize the contents of disks
according to the kind and use of the
data contained for example important
programs required to run the system are
often kept on a separate partition known
as root or slash this is a separate
partition than the one that contains
files owned by regular users of the
system in slash home in addition
temporary files created and destroyed
during the normal operation of Linux may
be located on dedicated partitions one
advantage of this kind of isolation by
type and variability is that when all
available space on a particular
partition is exhausted the system may
still operate normally
this picture shows the use of the G
parted utility which displays the
partition layout on a system which has
four operating systems on it roll eight
Cent OS 7 Ubuntu and Windows
before you can start using a file system
you need to mount it on the file system
tree at the mount point this is simply a
directory which may or may not be empty
where the file system is to be grafted
on sometimes you may need to create the
directory if it does not already exist
but keep in mind this warning if you
mount a file system on a non-empty
directory the former contents of that
directory are covered up and not
accessible until the file system is
unmounted thus Mount points are usually
empty directories
the mountain command is used to attach a
file system which can be local to the
computer or on a network somewhere
within the file system tree the basic
arguments are the device node and the
mount point for example pseudo Mount or
slash Dev slash sda5 slash home will
attach the file system contained in the
disk partition associated with the slash
Dev slash sda5 device node into the file
system tree at the slash home Mount
point there are other ways to specify
the partition other than the device node
such as using the disk label or the uuid
to unmount the partition the command
would be sudo u-mount slash home note
the command is u-mount not unmount only
a root user has the privilege to run
these commands unless the system has
been otherwise configured if you want it
to be automatically available every time
the system starts up you need to edit
the slash Etc fstab accordingly looking
at this style will show you the
configuration of all pre-configured file
systems man f-stab will display how this
file is used and how to configure it
executing Mount without any arguments
will show all presently mounted file
systems the command DF th disk free will
display information about Mountain file
systems including the file system type
and usage statistics about currently
used and available space
it's often necessary to share data
across physical systems which may be
either in the same location or anywhere
that can be reached by the internet a
network or distributed file system may
have alt data on one machine or have it
spread out on more than one network node
a variety of different file systems can
be used locally on the individual
machines a network file system can be
thought of as a grouping of lower level
file systems of varying types mini
system administrators Mount remote users
home directories on a server in order to
give them access to the same files and
configuration files across multiple
client systems this allows the users to
log into different computers you still
have access to the same files and
resources the most common such file
systems is named simply NFS the network
file system it has a very long history
and was first developed by Sun
Microsystems another common
implementation is cifs also termed Samba
which has Microsoft routes
in this section you will learn to
identify and differentiate between the
most important directories found in
Linux we start with ordinary users home
directory space each user has a home
directory usually placed under the slash
home the slash root directory on Modern
Linux systems is no more than the home
directory of the root user or super user
or system administrator account
on multi-user systems the slash home
directory infrastructure is often
mounted as a separate file system on its
own partition or even exported remotely
on a network through NFS sometimes you
may group users based on their
department or function you can then
create subdirectories under the slash
home directory for each of these groups
for example a school May organize home
with something like the following slash
Home factory home staff home students
the slash bin and slash S Pen directory
the slash bin directory contains
executable binaries essential commands
used to boot the system and essential
commands required by all system users
such as cat cpls MV PS and RM likewise
the slash S Pen directory is intended
for essential binaries related to system
administration such as fssck and IP to
view a list of these programs you can
type LS slash bin slash S Pen commands
that are not essential for the system to
boot or operate in single user mode are
placed in the slash user slash bin and
slash user slash S Pen directories
historically this was done so slash user
could be mounted as a separate file
system that could be mounted at a later
stage of system startup or even over a
network however nowadays most find this
distinction is obsolete in fact many
distributions have been discovered to be
unable to boot with this separation as
this modality had not been used or
tested for a long time thus on some of
the newest Linux distributions slash
user slash Spin and slash bin are
actually just symbolically linked
together as our slash user slash S ban
and slash S Pen
certain file systems like the one
mounted at slash proc are called pseudo
file systems because they have no
permanent presence anywhere on the disk
the slash proc file system contains
virtual files files that only exist in
memory that permit viewing constantly
changing kernel data slash proc contains
files and directories that mimic kernel
structures and configuration information
it does not contain real files but
runtime system information IG system
memory devices mounted Hardware
configuration Etc some important entries
in slash proc are the following
so let's broadcast subdirectories as
well including the following
the first example shows there is a
directory for every process running on a
system which contains Vital Information
about it the second example shows a
virtual directory that contains a lot of
information about the entire system in
particular it's hardware and
configuration the slash proc file system
is very useful because the information
and reports is gathered only as needed
and never needs storage on the disk
the slash Dev directory contains device
nodes a type of pseudo file used by most
hardware and software devices except for
network devices this directory is empty
on the disk partition when it's not
mounted and also contains entries which
are created by the udep system which
creates and manages device nodes on
Linux creating them dynamically when
devices are found the slash Dev
directory contains items such as slash
Dev sda1 the first partition on the
first hard disk slash Dash lp1 the
second printer slash Dev slash random a
source of random numbers
the slabs of VAR directory contains
files that are expected to change in
size and content as the system is
running VAR stands for a variable such
as the entries in the following
directories system log files slash log
and packages and database files like
slash lib print queues slash VAR slash S
Pool and temporary files slash TMP
the slash of our directory may be put on
its own file system so that growth of
the files can be accommodated and any
exploding file sizes do not fatally
affect the system network service
directories such as slash bar FTP the
FTP Service in slash www the HTTP web
service are also found under slash bar
the slash Etc directory is the home for
system config configuration files it
contains no binary programs although
there are some executable scripts for
example slash Etc
resolve.conf tells the system where to
go on the network to obtain hostname to
IP address mappings DNS files like
password Shadow and group for managing
user accounts are found in the slash Etc
directory while some distributions have
historically had their own extensive
infrastructure under slash Etc with the
admin of systemmd there is much more
uniformity among distributions today
note that slash Etc is for system-wide
configuration files and only the super
user can modify files there
user-specific configuration files are
always found under their home directory
this last boot directory contains the
few essential files needed to boot the
system for every alternative kernel
installed on the system there are these
four files VM Li news which is the
compressed Linux kernel required for
booting in it Ram FS which is the
initial Ram file system required for
booting sometimes called init Rd not in
it Ram fs and then config the kernel
configuration file only used for
debugging and bookkeeping and finally
system.map which is the kernel symbol
table only used for debugging each of
these files has a kernel version
appended to its name the grub files such
as boot grub slash grub.com or slash
boot slash grub2
grub2cfd are also found under the slash
boot directory this screenshot shows an
example listing of the slash boot
directory taken from the Rel system that
has multiple installed kernels including
both distribution supplied and custom
compiled ones names will Aryan things
will tend to look somewhat different on
a different distribution
slash lib contains libraries which is
which are common code shared by
applications and needed for them to run
it contains libraries for essential
programs in slash bin and slash S Bend
these Library file names either start
with LD or lib here's an example
most of these are what is known as
dynamically loaded libraries also known
as shared libraries or shared objects on
some Linux distributions there exists a
slash lib64 directory containing 64-bit
libraries while slash lib contains
32-bit versions on recent Linux
distributions you can find this
just like for slash bin and slash S bin
the directories just point to the those
under slash user kernel modules or
kernel code often device drivers that
can be loaded and unloaded without
restarting the system are located in
slash lib slash modules slash and then
the kernel version number
one often uses removable media such as
USB drives CDs and DVDs to make the
material accessible through the regular
file system it has to be mounted at a
convenient location most linked systems
are configured so any removable media
are automatically mounted when the
system notices something has been
plugged in while historically this was
done under the slash media directory
modern Linux distributions place these
Mount points under the slash run
directory for example a USB pin drive
with a label my USB drive for a user
named student will be mounted at slash
run slash media student slash my USB
drive the slash Mount directory has been
used since the early days of Unix for
temporarily mounting file systems these
can be those on removable media but more
often they might be Network file systems
which are not normally mounted or these
can be temporary partitions or so-called
loopback file systems which are files
which pretend to be partitions
here's some additional directories to be
found under the root directory
the slash user directory tree contains
theoretically non-essential programs and
scripts in the sense that they should
not be needed to initially boot the
system and has at least the following
subdirectories shown here
now that you know about the file system
and its structure let's learn how to
manage files and directories diff is
used to compare files and directories
this often used utility program has many
useful options including the ones you
see here
to compare two files at the command
prompt type diff and options file name 1
file name two diff is meant to be used
for text files for binary files one can
use CMP in this section you will learn
additional methods for comparing files
and how to apply patches to files
you can compare three files at once
using diff3 which uses one file as the
reference basis for the other two for
example suppose you and a co-worker both
have made modifications to the same file
working at the same time independently
diff 3 can show the differences based on
the common file you both started with
here's the Syntax for diff3
this graphic shows the use of diff3 many
modifications to source code and
configuration files are distributed
utilizing patches which were applied not
surprisingly with the pets program a
pets file contains the Deltas or changes
required to update an older version of a
file to the new one the patch files are
actually produced by running diff with
the correct options as in this command
Distributing just the patch is more
concise and efficient than Distributing
the entire file for example if only one
line needs to change in a file that
contains one thousand lines the patch
file will be just a few a few lines long
to apply patch you can just do either of
these two methods the first usage is
more common as it's often used to apply
changes to an entire directory tree
rather than just one file as in the
second example to understand the use of
the dash P1 option and many others see
the man page for patch
in Linux a files extension often does
not categorize it the way it might in
other operating systems one cannot
assume that a file name file.txt is a
text file and not an executable program
in Linux a file name is generally more
meaningful to the user of a system than
the system itself in fact most
applications directly examine a file's
contents to see what kind of app object
it is rather than relying on an
extension this is very different from
the way Windows handles file names where
a file naming ending in exe for example
represents an executable binary file the
real nature of a file can be determined
by using the file utility for the file
names given as arguments it examines the
contents and certain characteristics to
determine whether the files are plain
text shared libraries executable
programs scripts or something else
there are many ways you can backup data
or even your entire system basic ways to
do so include the use of simple copying
with CP and use of the more robust rsync
both can be used to synchronize entire
directory trees however our sync is more
efficient because it checks if the file
being copied already exists if the file
exists and there's no change in size or
modification time our sync will avoid an
unnecessary copy and save time
furthermore because our sync copies only
the parts of the file that have actually
changed it can be very fast
CP can only copy files to and from
destinations on the local machine but
rsync can also be used to copy files
from one machine to another
locations are designated in the Target
colon path form where Target can be the
form of someone at host and the someone
at part is optional and used if the
remote user is different from the local
user our sync is very efficient when
recursively copying One Directory tree
to another because only the differences
are transmitted over the network one
often synchronizes the destination
directory tree with the origin using the
dash R option to recursively walk down
the directory tree copying all files and
directories below the one listed as the
source
our sink is a very powerful utility for
example a very useful way to back up a
project directory might be to use this
command
note that rsync can be very destructive
accidental misuse can do a lot of harm
to data and programs by inadvertently
copying changes to where they are not
wanted take care to specify the correct
options and paths it's highly
recommended that you first test your RC
command using the dash dry dash run
option to ensure that it provides the
results that you want to use rsync at
the command prompt type rsync source
file destination file where either file
can be on the local machine or on a
network machine the contents of source
file will be copied to destination file
a good combination of options is shown
here
the file data is often compressed to
save disk space and reduce the time it
takes to transmit files over networks
Linux uses a number of methods to
perform this compression including these
these techniques vary in the efficiency
of the compression or how much space is
saved and how long they take to compress
generally the more efficient techniques
take longer decompression time does not
vary as much across different methods
you have completed chapter 10. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
the file system tree off starts at what
is often called the root directory or
trunk or slash the file system
hierarchical standard FHS provides Linux
developers and system administrators a
standard directory structure for the
file system
partitions help to segregate files
according to usage ownership and type
file systems can be mounted anywhere on
the main file system tree at a mount
Point automatic file systems mounting
can be set up by editing Etc fstab in a
fast or network file system is a useful
method for sharing files and data
through the network systems file systems
like slash proc are called pseudo file
systems because they exist only in
memory slash root is the home directory
for the root user slash VAR may be put
in its own file system so that growth
can be contained and not fatally affect
the system
slash boot contains the basic files
needed to boot the system patch is a
very useful tool in Linux many
modifications to source code and
configuration files are distributed with
patch files as they contain the Deltas
or changes to go from an old version of
a file to the new version of a file file
extensions in Linux do not necessarily
mean that a file is of a certain type
CP is used to copy files on the local
machine while rsync can be all can be
used to copy files from one machine to
another as well as synchronize contents
by the end of this chapter you should be
familiar with how to create and edit
files using the available Linux text
editors Nano a simple text-based editor
G edit a simple graphical editor VI and
emacs to Advanced editors with both
text-based and graphical interfaces
at some point you will need to manually
edit text files you might be composing
an email offline writing a script to be
used for bash or other command
interpreters altering a system or
application configuration file or
developing source code for a programming
language such as C python or Java Linux
administrators May sidestep using a text
editor instead employing graphical
utilities for creating and modifying
system configuration files however this
can be more laborious than directly
using a text editor and be more limited
in capability
note that word processing applications
including those that are part of common
Office application Suites are not really
basic text editors they add a lot of
extra usually invisible formatting
information that will probably render
system administration configuration
files unusable for their intended
purpose so knowing how to confidently
use one or more text editors is really
an essential skill to have for Linux by
now you have certainly realized Linux is
packed with choices when it comes to
text editors there are many choices
ranging from quite simple to very
complex including Nano G edit VI or
emacs
in this section we learned first about
the Nano and Geeta editors which are
relatively simple and easy to learn and
then later the more complicated choices
VI and emacs before we start let's take
a look at some cases where an editor is
not needed
sometimes you may want to create a short
file and don't want to bother invoking a
full text editor in addition doing so
can be quite useful when used from
within scripts even when creating longer
files you'll no doubt find yourself
using this method when you start on the
later chapters that cover shell skip
scripting if you want to create a file
without using an editor there are two
standard ways to create one from the
command line and fill it with content
the first one is to use Echo repeatedly
like shown here
note that while a single greater than
sign will send the output of a command
to a file two of them will append the
new output to an existing file the
second way is to use can't combined with
redirection
as in this example here
both techniques produce a file with the
following lines in it line one line two
line three
and are extremely useful when employed
by Scripts
there are some text editors that are
pretty obvious they require no
particular experience to learn and are
actually quite capable even robust
particularly easy to use one is the text
terminal base editor Nano just invoke
Nano by giving a file name as an
argument all the help you need is
displayed at the bottom of the screen
and you should be able to proceed
without any problem as a graphical
editor G edit is part of the gnome
desktop system K Wright is associated
with KDE the G edit and K write editors
are very easy to use and are extremely
capable they're also very configurable
they look a lot like notepad and windows
other variants such as Kate are also
supported by KDE Nano is easy to use and
requires very little effort to learn to
open a file type Nano and then the file
name and press enter if the file does
not exist it will be created Nano
provides a two-line shortcut at the
bottom of the screen that lists the
available commands so these commands are
Ctrl G display the help screen control o
right to a file Ctrl X execute exit a
file Ctrl R insert contents from another
file to the current buffer or control C
show the cursor position
G edit is a simple to use graphical
editor that can only be run within a
graphical desktop environment it is
visually quite similar to the notepad
text editor in Windows but it's actually
far more capable and very configurable
and has a wealth of plugins available to
extend its capabilities further
to open a new file find the program in
your desktop's menu system or from the
command line type G edit and then the
file name if the file does not exist it
will be created using G edit is pretty
straightforward and does not require
much training its interface is composed
of quite familiar elements
developers and administrators
experienced in working on unix-like
systems almost always use one of the two
venerable editing options VI and emacs
both are present or easily available on
all distributions and are completely
compatible with the versions available
on other operating systems both VI and
emacs have a basic purely text-based
form that can run in a non-graphical
environment they also have one or more
graphical interface forums with extended
capabilities these may be friendlier for
a less experienced user while VI and
emacs can have significantly steep
learning curves for new users they are
extremely efficient when one is learned
how to use them usually the actual
program installed on your system is vim
which stands for Vim proved and is
aliased to the name VI even if you don't
want to use VI it's good to gain some
familiarity with it it's a standard tool
installed on Virtual actually all Linux
distributions and Mac OS indeed there
may be times when there is no other
editor available on the system and
remember VI and them are going to be
very similar gnome extends VI with a
graphical interface known as gvm and KDE
offers cavem either of these may be
easier to use at first when using VI all
commands are entered through the
keyboard you don't need to keep moving
your hands to use a pointer device such
as a mouse or a touchpad unless you want
to do so when using one of the graphical
versions of the editor typing Vim tutor
launches a short but very comprehensive
tutorial for those who want to learn
their first VI commands even though it
provides only an introduction and just
seven lessons it has enough material to
make you a very proficient VI user
because it covers a large number of
commands after learning these basic ones
you can look up new tricks to
incorporate into your list of VI
commands because there are always more
optimal ways to do things in VI with
less typing VI provides three modes as
described in this table here it's vital
to not lose track of which mode you're
in many keystrokes and commands have
quite different behave quite differently
in different modes
this table describes the most important
commands used to start exit read and
write files in VI
the enter key needs to be pressed after
all these commands
and this table describes the most
important keystrokes used when changing
cursor positions in VI line mode
commands those following a colon require
the enter key to be pressed after the
command is typed
let's get started on using modes and
cursor movements in VI open VI by typing
VI followed by the file name VI opens in
command mode type I to enter insert mode
VI's insert mode is displayed type the
following sentences
the quick brown fox jumped over the lazy
dog nobody expects the Spanish
Inquisition to exit insert mode and
switch to command mode press Escape
to exit VI and save the file type colon
WQ and press enter
open the recently saved file and place
the cursor on the letter k in the word
quick in the first sentence to move the
cursor four characters to the left type
h four times the cursor is moved to
letter Q of the word quick to move the
cursor to the next line type J
to move the cursor to the beginning of
the next word type w the cursor is moved
to the beginning of the word expects to
move the cursor to the end type the
dollar sign the cursor is moved to the
end of the second sentence type I to
enter insert mode VI insert mode is
displayed to insert text at the end of
the second sentence type A and type
history the word history is displayed to
the end of the sentence to exit insert
mode and switch to command mode press
escape to exit VI and save the file type
colon WQ and press enter
here you can see the most important
commands used when searching for text in
VI the enter key should be pressed after
typing the search pattern
this table describes the most important
keystrokes used when searching for text
in VI
and this table describes the most
important keystrokes used when changing
adding and deleting text in VI
typing the sh command opens an external
command shell when you exit the shell
you will resume your editing session
piping exclamation point executes a
command from within VI the command
follows the exclamation point this
technique is best suited for
non-interactive commands such as
exclamation point WC percentage typing
this will run the word count command on
the file the character the percentage
represents the file currently being
edited
let's get started on using external
commands saving and closing in Vim
editor open VI editor by typing VI
followed by the file name VI opens in
command mode
type I to enter insert mode VI's insert
mode is displayed type the following
sentences nobody expects the Spanish
Inquisition nobody expects the 2020
Revolution to exit insert mode and
switch to command mode press escape to
write and quit the file type colon WQ
the file is updated with the changes
enclosed open VI by typing VI followed
by the file name
to count the words in the current file
type colon exclamation WC percent the
word count is displayed press enter to
continue editing to quit if no edits
were made in the file type colon queue
the file is closed open VI by typing VI
followed by file name
to quit without saving the file type
colon queue exclamation the file is
closed without saving the changes
the Emax editor is a popular competitor
for Vi unlike VI it does not work with
modes emacs is highly customizable and
includes a large number of features it
was initially designed for use on a
console but was soon adopted to work
with a GUI as well emacs has many other
capabilities other than Simple Text
editing for example it can be used for
email debugging and many other things
rather than having different modes for
command and insert like VI emacs uses
the control and meta or alt or Escape
keys for special commands here you can
see some of the most important key
combinations that are used when starting
exiting reading and writing files in
emacs
the emacs tutorial is a good place to
start learning basic commands it's
available anytime when in emacs by
simply typing Ctrl H for help and then
the letter t for tutorial we will now
demonstrate some of the operations you
can do with emacs in your daily work
so first let's get a file to edit so
working in the TMP directory let's get a
copy of Etc password and bring it over
here
and then in order to work on it I just
have to say emacs pass in the name of
the file
Now the default font here is a little
small so I'll play a trick and hit
control and the middle button of the
mouse to control the size of the font
and then I'll make the window a little
bigger
Okay so we've done that now suppose I
want to look for a certain string let's
say FTP I would hit Ctrl s and type in
the very bottom window at the very
bottom line here FTP so you can see down
here and you'll see it brought me to FTP
I'll go back to the beginning of the
line is hitting Ctrl a and then let's
say I want to change all occurrences of
the string FTP to something else I hit
Escape
percent Mark and then I'll say FTP again
and the bottom line
and then let's just do it backwards in
capitals PTF
and you see I hit space it does the
first one
space it does the second one space it
does the third one if I had hit an
exclamation point it would have done all
of them in the entire file
suppose I want to remove a line I can
just hit Ctrl K and it's gone Ctrl K is
gone again suppose I want to remove a
range of lines I hit control space and
then I
go down a few lines uh with either the
arrow key or control N I hit Ctrl w
and they're gone if I want to move them
further on in the file
I go down a few lines and I hit Ctrl y
for yank
and they're back in there
one nice thing I can do with emacs is
open up multiple windows at the same
time so let me hit Ctrl x 2 and now I've
got two windows and I can switch to the
bottom window by hitting Ctrl x o for
other
and then I hit control x f i could put a
different file in that buffer so let's
say I put in ETC group
okay once again I'll make the font a
little bigger by hitting control and the
middle button on the mouse
okay and you'll notice the bottom line
is actually uh right protected so I
can't really delete anything because it
belongs to root if I try to delete this
line it won't let me do it it says
buffer is read only
but in general like if I had two files
with the same permissions I could cut
and paste and go from one to the other
to get back to just one I can do control
X1 and I have only this but if I really
wanted the other window I could hit Ctrl
xB
and I'm back in the password file
if I want to rewrite it I can hit Ctrl x
w
control X control W and that would let
me write it as a different name so I'll
say p-a-s-w-d
revised
and it's there if I want to terminate
the program I say control x s
make sure things have been saved and
then control XC
and I'm done so you can see we use the
control key quite a bit in Emax the
position most keyboards put it in these
days is a little unnatural all the way
at the bottom left or right
so veteran Emax users tend to remap the
keyboard so that the caps lock key also
works as control
so that's some of the basic operations
you would do in day-to-day use of emacs
you have completed chapter 11. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
text editors rather than word processing
programs are used quite often in Linux
for tasks such as creating or modifying
system configuration files writing
scripts developing source code and more
Nano is an easy to use text-based editor
that utilizes on-screen prompts G edit
is a graphical editor very similar to
notepad and windows the vi editor is
available on all Linux systems and is
very widely used graphical extension
versions of VI are widely available as
well the max is available on all Linux
systems as a popular alternative to VI
emacs can support both a graphical user
interface and a text mode interface to
access the vi tutorial type Vim tutor at
a command line window to access the
emacs tutorial type control h and then T
from within emacs VI is three modes
command insert and line emacs has only
one but requires use of special keys
such as control and Escape
both editors use various combinations of
keystrokes to accomplish tasks the
learning curve to master these can be
long but once mastered using either
editor is extremely efficient
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to use and configure user accounts
and user groups use and set environment
variables use the previous shell command
history
use keyboard shortcuts
use and Define aliases
use and set file permissions and
ownership
as you know Linux is a multi-user
operating system meaning more than one
user can log on at the same time
to identify the current user type who am
I to list the currently logged on users
type who
giving who the dash a option will give
more detailed information
in Linux the command shell program
generally bash uses one or more startup
files to configure the user environment
files in the slash Etc directory define
global settings for all users while
initialization files in the user's home
directory can include and or override
the global settings
the startup files can do anything the
user would like to do in every command
shell
such as customizing The Prompt defining
command line shortcuts and aliases
setting the default text editor setting
the path for where to find executable
Pro or setting the path for where to
find executable programs
the standard prescription is that when
you first log into Linux slash Etc
profile is read and evaluated after
which the following files are searched
if they exist in this order dot batch
profile dot bash login dot profile where
the squiggly line slash dot denotes the
user's home directory the Linux login
shell evaluates whatever startup file
that it comes across first and ignores
the rest this means that if it finds dot
batch profile it ignores dot best login
and Dot profile
different distributions may use
different startup files however every
time you create a new shell or terminal
window you do not have to perform a full
system login only a file name dot bat RC
file is read and evaluated although this
file is not read and evaluated along
with the login shell most distributions
and or users include the dot bash RC
file from within one of the three
user-owned startup files
most commonly users only fiddle with the
dot bashrc as it is it is invoked every
time a new command line shell initiates
or another program is launched from a
trauma window while the other files are
read and executed only when the user
first logs on to the system
recent distributions sometimes do not
even have bash profile and or bash login
and some just do little more than
include dot bash RC
you can create customized commands or
modify the behavior of already existing
ones by creating aliases most often
these aliases are placed in your bashrc
file so they're available to any command
shells you create on Alias removes an
alias
typing Alias with no argument will list
currently defined aliases
please note that there should not be any
spaces on either side of the equal sign
and the Alias definition needs to be
placed within either single or double
quotes if it contains any spaces
all Linux users are assigned a unique
user ID uid which is just an integer
normal users start with a uid of 1000 or
greater Linux uses groups for organizing
users groups are collections of accounts
with certain shared permissions control
of group membership is administered
through the slash Etc group file which
shows a list of groups and their members
by default every user belongs to a
default or primary group when a user
logs in the group membership is set for
their primary group and all the members
enjoy the same level of access and
privilege permissions on various files
and directories can be modified at the
group level users also have one or more
group IDs GID including a default one
which is the same as the user ID these
numbers are associated with names
through the files slash Etc password and
slash Etc group groups are used to
establish a set of users who have common
interests for the purpose of x success
rights Privileges and security
considerations
access rights to files and devices are
granted on the basis of the user and the
group they belong to
distributions have straightforward
graphical interfaces for creating and
removing users and groups and
manipulating group membership however
it's often useful to do it from the
command line or from within shell
scripts only the root user can add and
remove users and groups adding a new
user is done with user ad and removing
an existing user is done with user Dell
in the simplest form an account for the
new user BJ moose would be done with
sudo user ad BJ moose which by default
sets the home directory to slash home
slash BJ moose populates it with some
basic files copied from slash Etc skell
and adds a line to the slash ett slash
password such as this
and sets the default shell to slash spin
slash bash removing a user account is as
easy as typing user Dell BJ moose
however this will leave the slash home
slash BJ moose directory intact this
might be useful if it's a temporary
inactivation to remove the home
directory while removing the account one
needs to use the dash R option to user
Dell
typing ID with no arguments gives gives
information about the current user as in
this ID
if given the name of another user as an
argument ID will record information
about that other user
let's get some experience with creating
modifying and removing a new user
account we will do this on Ubuntu 1704.
there are some variations between
distributions about what exactly is
created when a new account is is created
and exactly which files are there Etc
this is mostly controlled by a file
under
Etc default
user ad appropriately named
so you can see for example in here the
default shell is set to be shell bsh bin
sh
now on some distributions such as red
hat this files rather short and not very
well documented on Ubuntu is rather long
so let's create the account as you do
a user ad and I'll say Dash M to make
sure it creates a home directory some
uh some distributions do not do that by
default the Ubuntu does not for instance
and neither does open Souza I'll give
the full name to be
Eric dolphy
I'll specify the default shell to be bin
bash with the S option
and here's the name e d o l p h y e
dolphin
now I still have to pass a specify a
password so I'll do that whatever you do
past w d e d o l p h y and then I type
something
and now the accounts exist and I can
verify that by making sure entries were
made
uh in the etcy
password file and etcy group
and there we go notice it is now user
1001 remember normal users start at 1000
and student is user 1000 and so that's
appropriate
and also the other information I
specified is there such as the full
username and the shell bin Bash
and the group is set to be 1001
which is the same ID as the user all
users are created with at least one
group that has the same number as their
username
now let's actually try to log into that
account and I'll do that with SSH
and
e-d-o-l-p-h-y at localhost
and I'll give the password
and I succeeded just fine
so let's see what's actually in that
directory
and you'll see there isn't much but
these are files that all new users get
um and let me log out now and that's
controlled by whatever's in the ETC skel
directory anything you put in there
let me do the a option anything you put
in there
will show up in any new users
account
so let's just clean up and I'll do that
with user
Del Dash R uh e dolphy
and the
R is necessary to make sure it removes
the home directory
you know as I get a warning message
about not having created a mail spool
file that's harmless
and if you do lssl on home now we see
the account is gone so we're all cleaned
up
adding a new group is done with group AD
so you can use sudo slash user slash S
Pen slash group AD a new group the group
can be removed with
sudo slash user slash S Pen slash group
Dell a new group
adding a user to an already existing
group is done with user mod for example
when you would first look at what groups
the user already belongs to
and then add the new group
sudo slash user slash S Pen slash user
mod Dash a dash G in your group RDS
squirrel RJ squirrel and then groups RJ
squirrel will show the new group
these utilities update the slash Etc
group as necessary make sure you use the
dash a option for append so as to avoid
removing already existing groups group
mod can be used to change group
properties such as the group ID with the
dash G option or its name with the with
the dash in option removing a user from
the group is somewhat trickier the dash
G option to user mod must give a
complete list of groups thus if you do
pseudo slash user slash S Pen slash user
mod Dash g r j squirrel RJ squirrel and
then do groups RJ squirrel you'll see
that only the RJ squirrel group will be
left
the root account is very powerful and
has full access to the system other
operating systems often call this the
administrator account in Linux it's
often called the super user account you
must be extremely cautious before
granting full root access to a user it's
rarely if ever Justified external
attacks often consist of tricks used to
elevate the root account however you can
use sudo to assign more limited
privileges to user accounts but only do
it on a temporary basis and only for a
specific subset of commands
when assigning elevated privileges you
can use the command Su the switch or
substitute user to launch a new shell
running as another user you must type
the password of the user you are
becoming most often this other user is
root and the new shell allows the use of
elevated privileges until it's until it
is exceeded it's almost always a bad
practice to use slsu to become root
resulting errors can include deletion of
vital files from the system and security
breaches
granting privileges using Sudo is less
dangerous and is preferred by default
Studio must be enabled on a per user
basis however some distributions such as
Ubuntu enable it by default for at least
one main user or give this as an
installation option
to temporarily become the super user for
a series of commands you can type Su and
then be prompted for the root password
to execute just one command with root
privileges type sudo and then the
command when the command is complete you
will return to being a normal
unprivileged user
sudo configuration files are stored in
the slash Etc sudoers file and in the
slash Etc
pseudoers.d directory by default the
pseudoers.directory is empty and
whenever you talk about sudo in a course
or article you're basically required to
show this webcomic by XKCD
environment variables are quantities
that have specific values which may be
utilized by the command shell such as
bash or other utilities and applications
some environment variables are given
preset values by the system which can
usually be overridden While others are
set directly by the user either at the
command line or within startup and other
scripts an environment variable is
actually just a character string that
contains information used by one or more
applications there are a number of ways
to view the values of currently set
environment variables one can type set
EMV or export depending on the state of
your system set May print out many more
lines than the other two methods
by default variables created within a
script are only available to the current
shell child processes subshells will not
have access to values that have been set
or modified allowing child processes to
see the values requires use of the
export command
you can also set environment variables
to be fed as a one shot to a command as
in the following
this feeds the values of the Esters and
K root environment variables to the
command make modules install
home is an environment variable that
represents the home or login directory
of the user
CD without arguments will change the
current working directory to the value
of home
note the tilde character is often used
as an abbreviation for home thus CD home
and CD with utility are completely
equivalent statements
foreign
path is an ordered list of directories
the path which is scanned when a command
is given to find the appropriate program
or script to run each directory in the
path is separated by colons a null or
empty directory name or slash indicates
the current directory at any given time
so in this example there is a null
directory before the first colon
similarly for this there is a null
directory between path 1 and path 2.
to prefix a private bin directory to to
your path you can use this command
the environment variable shell points to
the user's default command shell the
program that is handling whatever you
type in a command window usually bash
and it contains the Full path name to
the Shell
prompt statement or Ps is used to
customize your prompt string in your
terminal Windows to display the
information you want PS1 is the primary
prompt variable which controls what your
command line prompt looks like
the following special characters can be
included in PS1
they must be surrounded in single quotes
when they are used as in this example
bash keeps track of previously entered
commands and statements in a history
buffer you can recall previously used
commands simply by using the up and down
cursor keys to view the list of
previously executed commands you can
just type history at the command line
this list of commands is displayed with
the most recent command appearing last
in the list this information is stored
in the slash dash dash history if you
have multiple terminals open the
commands typed in each session are not
saved until the session terminates
several Associated environment variables
can be used to get information about the
history pile his file is the location of
the history file his file size is the
maximum number of lines in the history
file default 500 his size is the maximum
number of commands in the history file
his control is how commands are stored
hist ignore is which command lines can
be unsaved for a complete description of
the the use of these environment
variables see the man page and Bash
there are specific keys to perform
various tasks if you want to recall a
command in the history list but do not
want to press the arrow key repeatedly
you can press Ctrl R to do a reverse
intelligent search as you start typing
the search goes back in reverse order to
the First Command that matches the
letters you have typed by typing more
successive letters you make the match
more and more specific
you can use keyboard shortcuts to
perform different tasks quickly this
table lists some of these keyboard
shortcuts and their uses note the case
of the hotkey does not matter meaning
doing control a is the same as doing
control capital a
in Linux and other Unix based operating
systems every file is associated with a
user who is the owner every file is also
associated with a group a subset of all
users which has an interest in the file
and certain rights or permissions read
write and execute the following utility
programs involve user and group
ownership and permission settings
files have three kinds of permissions
read write and execute these are
generally represented as the rwx these
permissions affect the three groups of
owners owner user owner group and others
as a result you have the following three
groups of three permissions there are a
number of different ways to use chmod
for instance to give the owner and
others execute permission and remove the
group write permission you can do this
where the U stands for user or owner o
stands for other world and G stands for
group
this kind of syntax can be difficult to
type and remember so one often uses a
shorthand which lets you set all the
permissions in one step this is done
with a simple algorithm and a single
digit suffices to specify all three
permission bits for each entity this
digit is the sum of four if read
permission is desired two if right
permission is desired one if execute
permission is desired so 7 means read
write execute six means read write 5
means read execute when you apply this
to the the chmod command you have to
give three digits for each degree of
Freedom such as chmod 755 sum file
now let's see an example of changing
file ownership using CH own as shown in
this screenshot
first we create two empty files using
touch
notice it requires sudo to change the
owner of file 2 to root the second CH
ohm command changes both owner and group
at the same time
finally only the super user can remove
the files now let's see an example of
changing the group ownership using
chgrep
you have completed chapter 12. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
Linux is a multi-user system
to find the currently logged on users
you can use the who command to find the
current user ID you can use the who am I
command
the root account has full access to the
system it's never sensible to Grant full
root access to a user you can assign
root privileges to regular user accounts
on a temporary basis using the sudo
command
the shell program or bash uses multiple
startup files to create the user
environment each file affects the
interactive environment in a different
way slash ectc profile provides the
global settings
advantages of startup files include that
they customize the user's prompt set the
user's terminal type set the command
line shortcuts and aliases and set the
default text editor an environment
variable is a character string that
contains data used by one or more
applications the built-in shell
variables can be customized to suit your
requirements the history command recalls
a list of previous commands which can be
edited and recycled in Linux various
keyboard shortcuts can be used at the
command prompt instead of long actual
commands you can customize commands by
creating aliases adding an alias to the
slash.rc file will make it available for
other shells file permissions can be
changed by typing chmod permissions in
the file name file ownership is changed
by typing CH own then the owner and the
file name the file group ownership is
changed by typing CHC Erp then the group
then the file name
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to display and append to file
contents using cat and Echo edit and
print file content to contents using SED
and ewk search for patterns using grep
use multiple other utilities for file
and text manipulation
irrespective of the role you play with
Linux such as system administrator
developer or user you often need to
browse through and parse text files and
or extract data from them these are file
manipulation operations thus it's
essential for the Linux user to become
Adept at performing certain operations
on files most of the time such file
manipulation is done at the command line
which allows users to perform tasks more
efficiently than while using a GUI
furthermore the command line is more
suitable for automating often executed
tasks indeed experienced system
administrators write customized scripts
to accomplish such repetitive tasks
standardized for each particular
environment we'll discuss such scripting
later in much detail
in this section we'll concentrate on
command line file and text manipulation
related utilities
cat is short for concatenate and is one
of the most frequently used Linux
command line utilities it's often used
to read and print files as well as for
simply viewing file contents to view a
file use the following command cat and
then the file name
for example cat readme.txt will display
the contents of readme.txt on the
terminal however the main purpose of cat
is often to combine or concatenate
multiple files together you can perform
the actions listed in this table using
cat
the tech command or cat spelled
backwards prints the lines of a file in
reverse order each line Remains the Same
but the order of lines is inverted the
syntax of TAC is exactly the same as for
cat as in the following
cat can be used to read from standard
input such as the terminal window if no
files are specified you can use the
greater than operator to create and add
new lines to file and the double greater
than operator to append lines or files
to an existing file to create a new file
at the command prompt type cat greater
than file name and press the enter key
this command creates a new file and
waits for the user to edit or enter the
text after you finish typing the
required text press Ctrl D at the
beginning of the next line to save and
exit the editing
let's demonstrate some of the basic
operations you can perform with the cat
utility where the word cat stands for
concatenate
it's typically used to copy files
combine them Etc so first we will need a
couple of simple text files to play with
let's create one using a text editor
let's say Nano so Nano file 1. text
and I will just type in a couple of
lines actually three lines with a point
one at the end I hit control X for exit
I say yes I want to save the modified
buffer and I keep the name
so now I can look at the the file
created with cat so I do cat file one to
text
perfect
now let's create another one
interactively using cat itself as we
talked about earlier so I can say cat
in their Direction with elf and I'll put
it into file 2.txt
and here is a second file with a few
lines
and then I just type eof on a line
and that
closes the input phase and I can say cat
file 2.6
it's there if I want to see them both
together I can say cat file one the text
file two dot text
I see a combined or I could send it into
a third file file three that text
and then clear the screen I can say cat
file three
a text and I see the combined
two files in a third file
so this is how we use CAD it's an
everyday operation you rarely do
anything that much more complicated with
it
system administrators need to work with
configuration files text files
documentation files and log files some
of these files may be larger or become
quite large as they accumulate data with
time these files will require both
viewing and administrative updating in
this section you will learn how to
manage such large files for example a
banking system might maintain one simple
large log file to record details of all
of One day's ATM transactions due to a
security attack or a malfunction the
administrator might be forced to check
for some data by navigating within the
file in such cases directly opening the
file in an editor will cause issues due
to high memory utilization as an editor
we'll usually try to read the whole file
into memory first however one can use
less to view the contents of such a
large file scrolling up and down Page by
Page without the system having to place
the entire file in memory before
starting this is much faster than and
using a text editor viewing some file
can be done by typing either of the two
following commands less some file or cat
some file pipe less
by default Man pages are sent through
the less command you may have
encountered the older more utility which
has some basic functionality but fewer
capabilities I.E less is more
head reads the first few lines of each
named file 10 by default and displays it
on standard output you can give a
different number of lines in an option
for example if you want to print the
first five lines from Etc slash default
scrub we can use this command head Dash
in and then Etc default scrub you can
also just do this head Dash 5 Etc
default scrub
tail prints the last few lines of each
named file and displays it on standard
output by default it's it displays the
last 10 lines you can give a different
number of lines as an option tail is
especially useful when you are
troubleshooting any issue using log
files as you probably want to see the
most recent lines of output for example
this to display the last 15 lines of
some file.log we can use this command
tail Dash end 15 some file that log you
can also just do this
tail that's 15 some file that log
continually monitor new output in a
growing log file we can do tail Dash F
some follow that log this command will
continuously display any new lines of
output in some file.log as soon as they
appear thus it enables you to monitor
any current activity that is being
reported and recorded
it's very common to create and then
repeatedly edit and or extract contents
from a file let's learn how to use SED
and awk to easily perform such
operations
note that many Linux users and
administrators will write scripts using
comprehensive scripting languages such
as Python and Perl rather than use SED
and awk and some of the other utilities
we'll discuss later using such utilities
is certainly fine in most circumstances
one should always feel free to use the
tools one is experienced with however
the utilities that are described here
are much lighter I.E they use fewer
system resources and execute faster
there are situations such as during
booting the system where a lot of time
would be wasted using the more
complicated tools and the system may not
even be able to run them so the simpler
tools will always be needed
SED is a powerful text processing tool
and is one of the oldest earliest and
most powerful Unix utilities it's used
to modify the contents of a file or
input stream usually placing the
contents into a new file or output
stream its name is is an abbreviation
for stream editor
said SED can filter text as well as
perform substitutions in data streams
data from an input source or file is
taken and moved to a working space the
entire list of operations or
modifications is applied over the data
in the working space and then file
contents are moved to the standard
output space or stream you can invoke
Saturn sdd using commands like those
listed in this table the dash e option
allows you to specify multiple editing
commands simultaneously at the command
line it's unnecessary if you only have
one operation invoked now that you know
that you can perform multiple editing
and filtering operations with said let's
explain some of them in more detail the
table explains some basic operations
where pattern is the current string and
replace underscore string is the new
string
let's demonstrate some of the most
Elementary operations you can perform
with SCD on a fedora system
so I have taken the Liberty to prepare a
simple text file uh before we start
which looks like this cat in file that
text
it just says three lines indicating
their presence
so balls I do
scd-e slash
and then let's say is to R
on the file
and the output will go right on standard
out
and you see it changed only the first
instance on every line so I even have
VAR instead of this
um I can make a slight modification to
the command if I put a g at the end of
it
and you see this time we caught every
instance
I could also do
something like this one comma 2s
and it only did it on the first and the
second line but I left the third line
alone
you'll notice that I don't have to use a
forward slash I can use many other
characters so here I'll use a colon
and it makes no difference what I use
now there is an option for SED to change
character streams in place on the
original file but it's a pretty
dangerous operation to do since you
destroying the original file so
generally it's better to send the output
into another file so I'll do I'll call
that one out file.txt
oh I forgot to say infile.text for input
so it hung so
now I can look at out file.text
you see and that's the output and if I
want to use the diff command to see the
difference I can do something like this
diff in file.text
Al file dot text
and it shows me the two lines that have
changed
now you can do some pretty complicated
things with SCD when you're trying to
deal with special characters including
spaces and question marks and stars life
can get pretty complicated it it
respects everything in the world about
what are called regular Expressions
which can look rather strange but it's a
daily tool that's just the
administrators do to make Elementary
substitutions and files
so that's a little bit about SCD
awk awk is used to extract and then
print specific contents of a file is
often used to construct reports it was
created at Bell labs in the 1970s and
derived its name from the last names of
its authors akes the following features
it's a powerful utility and interpreted
programming language it's used to
manipulate data files and for retrieving
and processing text it works well with
Fields containing a single piece of data
essentially a column and Records a
collection of fields essentially a line
in a file
awk is invoked as shown in this example
as was said short op commands can be
specified directly at the command line
but a more complex script can be saved
in a file that you can specify using the
dash F option
this table explains the basic tasks that
can be performed using awk the input
file is read one line at a time and for
each line awk matches the given pattern
in the given order and performs a
requested action the dash F option
allows you to specify a particular field
separator character for example the
slash Etc password file uses a colon to
separate Fields so the dash F colon
option is used with the slash EDC slash
password file the command or action in
AUC needs to be surrounded with
apostrophes or single quotes awk can be
used like the following like in this
example
in managing your files you may need to
perform tasks such as sorting data and
copying data from one location to
another Linux provides numerous file
manipulation utilities that you can use
while working with text files in this
section you will learn about the
following file manipulation programs
sort unique paste join and split you
also learn about regular expressions and
search patterns
sort is used to rearrange the lines of a
text file in either ascending or
descending order according to a sort key
you could also sort with respect to
particular fields or columns in a file
the default sort key is the order of the
ASCII characters I.E essentially
alphabetically so it can be used like
this
when used with the dash U option sort
checks for Unique values after sorting
the records or lines it's basically
equivalent to running unique on the
output of sort
unique removes duplicate consecutive
lines in a text file and it's useful for
simplifying the text display because
unique requires that the duplicate
entries must be consecutive when often
run sort first and then pipes output
into unique if sort is used with the
dash U option it can do all this in one
step to remove duplicate entries from
multiple files at once use this command
or you can use do this one
to count the number of duplicate entries
use this command
suppose you have a file that contains
the full name of all employees and
another file that lists their phone
numbers and employee IDs you want to
create a new file that contains all the
data listed in three columns name
employee ID and phone number how can you
do this effectively without investing
too much time Paste can be used to
create a single file containing all
three columns the different columns are
identified based on delimiters which is
spacing used to separate two fields for
example delimiters can be a blank space
a tab or an enter in this image a single
space is used as a delimiter in all
files
paste accepts the following options Dash
D for the delimiters which specify a
list of delimiters to be used instead of
tabs for separating consecutive values
on a single line each delimiter is used
in turn when the list has been exhausted
Pace begins again at the first delimiter
dash s which causes Pace to append the
data in series rather than in parallel
that is in a horizontal rather than
vertical fashion
Paste can be used to combine Fields such
as name or phone number from different
files as well as combine lines from
multiple files for example Line 1 from
file 1 can be combined with line 1 of
file 2 and line 2 from file 1 can be
combined with line 2 of file two and so
on to paste contents from two files one
can do this
and here's the syntax to use a different
delimiter
common delimiters are space Tab and
comma
suppose you have two files with with
similar columns you have saved employees
phone numbers and two files one with the
first name and the other with their last
name you want to combine the files
without repeating the data of common
columns how do you achieve this
this task can be achieved using join
which is essentially an enhanced version
of paste it first checks whether the
files share common fields such as names
or phone numbers and then joins the
lines and two files based on a common
field to combine two files on a common
field at the common prompt type join
file one file 2 and press the enter key
for example the common field I.E it
contains the same values among the phone
book and cities files is the phone
number and the result of joining these
two files is shown here
split is used to break up or split a
file into equal size segments for easier
viewing and manipulation and it's
generally used only on relatively large
files by default split breaks up a file
into 1000 line segments the original
file remains unchanged and a set of new
files with the same name plus added
prefix is created by default the X
prefix is added to split a file the
segments use the command split and file
to split file into segments using a
different prefix use the command split
in file and then the prefix we will
apply split to an American English
dictionary file of over 99
000 lines and in this example we've used
WC which stands for word count that
we'll discuss shortly to report on the
number of lines in the file and then you
just type this
this will split the American English
style into 100 equal size segments named
dictionary XX the last one will of
course be somewhat smaller
regular expressions are text strings
used for matching a specific pattern or
to search for a specific location such
as the start or end of a line or a word
regular Expressions can contain both
normal characters or so-called meta
characters such as an asterisk or an and
a dollar sign many text editors and
utilities such as VI said OC find and
grep work extensively with regular
Expressions this table lists the search
patterns and their usage
for example consider the following
sentence the quick brown fox jumped over
the lazy dog some of the patterns that
can be applied to the sentence are shown
here
grep is extensively used as a primary
text searching tool it scans files for
specified patterns and it can be used
with regular Expressions as well as
simple strings as shown in this table
strings is used to extract all printable
character strings found in a file or
files given as arguments it's useful in
locating human readable content embedded
in binary files for text files one can
just use grep for example to search for
the string my underscore string in a
spreadsheet you can use this command
and this screenshot shows a search of a
number of programs to see which ones
have GPL licenses of various versions
in this section you will learn about
some additional text utilities that you
can use for performing various actions
on your Linux files such as changing the
case of letters or determining the count
of words lines and characters in a file
the TR utility is used to translate
specified characters into other
characters or to delete them the general
syntax is as follows TR options set 1
and set 2. the items in the square
brackets are optional TR requires at
least one argument and accepts a maximum
of two the first designated set one in
this example lists the characters in the
text to be replaced or removed the
second set two lists the characters that
are to be substituted for the characters
listed in the first argument sometimes
these sets need to be surrounded by
apostrophes or single quotes in order to
have the shell ignore that they mean
something special to the Shell it's
usually safe and may be required to use
the single quotes around around each of
the sets as you'll see in these examples
for example suppose you have a file
named City containing several lines of
attacks in mixed case to translate all
lowercase characters to uppercase at the
command prompt type cat City pipe TR adz
adfz and press the enter key
takes the output from any command and
while sending to the standard output it
also saves it in a file in other words
it tees the output stream from the
command one stream is displayed on the
standard output and the other is saved
to a file
for example to list the contents of a
directory on the screen and save the
output to a file at the command prompt
type ls-l pipe T new file and press
enter key typing can't new file will
then display the output of ls-l
WC or word count counts the number of
lines words and characters in a file or
a list of files options are given in
this table
by default all three of these options
are active
cut is used for manipulating column
based files and is designed to extract
specific columns the default column
separator is the tab character different
deliminator can be given as a command
option for example to display the third
column delimited by a blank space at the
command prompt type ls-s pipe cut Dash d
double quote space double quote and then
Dash F3 and then you press the enter key
you have completed chapter 13. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered
the command line often allows the users
to perform tasks more efficiently than
the GUI
cat sort 4 concatenate is used to read
print and combine files Echo displays a
line of text either on standard output
or to place in a file set is a popular
stream editor often used to filter and
perform substitutions on files and Text
data streams awk is an interpretive
programming language typically used as a
data extraction and reporting tool
sort is used to sort text files and
output streams in either ascending or
descending order
unique eliminates duplicate entries in a
text file paste combines fields from
different files you can also extract and
combine lines from multiple sources join
combines lines from two files based on a
common field it works only if files
share a common field split breaks up a
large file into equal size segments
regular expressions are text strings
used for pattern matching the pattern
can be used to search for a specific
location such as the start or end of a
line or a word
grep searches the text files and data
streams for patterns and can be used
with regular expressions
TR translates characters copy standard
input to standard output and handle
special characters
T saves a copy of standard output to a
file while still displaying at the
terminal WC for word count displays the
number of lines words and characters in
a file or a group of files cut extracts
columns from a file less views files a
page at a time and allow scrolling in
both directions head displays the first
few lines of the file or data stream or
standard standard output by default it
displays 10 lines tail displays the last
few lines of a file or data stream on
standard output by default it displays
10 lines strings extracts printable
character strings from binary files
by the end of this chapter you should be
able to explain basic networking
Concepts including types of networks and
addressing issues configure network
interfaces and use it and use basic
networking utilities such as ifconfig IP
ping route and trace route use graphical
and non-graphical browsers such as links
w3m Firefox Chrome and Epiphany transfer
files to and from clients and servers
using both graphical and text mode
applications such as filezilla FTP SFTP
curl and wget
a network is a group of computers and
Computing devices connected together
through communication channels such as
cables or wireless media the computers
connected over a network may be located
in the same geographical area or spread
across the world a network is used to
allow the connected devices to
communicate with each other enable
multiple users to share devices over the
network such as music and video servers
printers and scanners
share and manage information across
computers easily
most organizations have both an internal
Network and an internet connection for
users to communicate with machines and
people outside the organization
the internet is the largest Network in
the world and can be called the network
of Networks
devices attached to a network must have
at least one unique Network address
identifier known as the IP or Internet
Protocol address the address is
essential for routing packets of
information through the network
exchanging information across the
network requires using streams of small
packets Each of which contains a piece
of the information going from one
machine to another these packets contain
data buffers together with headers which
contain information about where the pack
is going to and coming from and where it
fits in the sequence of packets that
constitute the Stream
Network Protocols are in software are
rather complicated due to the diversity
of machines and operating systems they
must deal with as well as the fact that
even very old standards must be
supported
there are two different types of IP
addresses available
ipv4 version 4 and IPv6 version 6. ipv4
is older and by far the most widely used
while IPv6 is newer and is designed to
get past limitations inherent in the
older standard in furnace many more
possible addresses ip4 uses 32-bits for
addresses they're only 4.3 billion
unique addresses available furthermore
many addresses are allotted and reserved
but not actually used ipv4 is considered
inadequate for meeting future needs
because the number of devices available
on the global network has increased
enormously in recent years
IPv6 uses 128 bits for addresses this
allows for a 3.4 times 10 to the power
of 38 unique addresses if you have a
larger network of computers and want to
add more you may want to move to IPv6
because it provides more unique
addresses however it can be complex to
migrate to IPv6 the two protocols do not
always interoperate well thus moving
equipment and addresses to IPv6 require
significant effort and has not been
quite as fast as was originally intended
we'll discuss ipv4 more than IPv6 as
you're more likely to deal with it one
reason ipv4 has not disappeared is there
are ways to effectively make many more
addresses available by methods such as
Nat the network address translation net
enables sharing one IP address among
many locally connected computers Each of
which has a unique address only seen on
the local network while this is used in
organizational settings it's also used
in simple home networks for example if
you have a router hooked up to your
internet provider such as a cable system
it gives you one externally visible
address but issues each device in your
home an individual local address
a 32-bit ipv4 address is divided into
four 8-bit sections called octets so
here's an example
note that octet is just another word for
byte Network addresses are divided into
five classes a b c d and e classes a B
and C are classified into two parts
Network addresses netid and host address
host ID the netid is used to identify
the network while the host ID is used to
identify a host in the network class D
is used for special multicast
applications information is broadcast to
multiple computers simultaneously in
class E is reserved for future use in
this section you will learn about
classes a b and c
Class A addresses use the first octet of
an IP address as their net ID and use
the other three octets as their host ID
the first bit of the first octet is
always set to zero so you can only use
seven bits for Unique Network numbers as
a result there are a maximum of 126
Class A networks available not
surprisingly this was only feasible when
there were very few unique networks with
large numbers of hosts as the use of the
internet expanded classes B and C were
added in order to accommodate the
growing the growing demand for
independent Networks
each class a network can have up to 16.7
million unique hosts on its Network the
range of host addresses is from
1.0.0.0 to 127.255.255.255
Class B addresses use the first two
octets of their IP address as their
netid and the last two octets as their
host ID the first two bits of the first
octet are always set to Binary 10. so
there are a maximum of 16 384 Class B
networks the first octet of a Class B
address has values from 128 to 191. the
introduction of Class B networks
expanded the number of networks but but
it soon became clear that a further
level would be needed each class B
Network can support a maximum of 65 536
unique hosts on its Network the range of
post addresses is from
128.0.0.0 to 191.255.255.255
Class C addresses use the first three
octets of the IP address as their net ID
in the last octet as their host IDE the
first three bits of the first octet are
set to Binary one one zero so almost 2.1
million Class C networks are available
the first octet of a Class C address has
values from 19192 to 223 these are most
common for smaller networks which don't
have many unique hosts each class seed
Network can support up to 256 unique
hosts the range of host addresses is
from
192.0.0.0 to 223.255.255.255
typically a range of IP addresses are
requested from your internet service
provider your ISP by your organization's
network administrator often your choice
of which class of IP address you're
given depends on the size of your
network and expected growth needs if Nat
is an operation such as in a home
network you only get one externally
visible address you can assign IP
addresses to computers over a network
either manually or dynamically manual
assignment adds static or never changing
addresses to the network dynamically
assigned addresses can change every time
you reboot or even more often the
dynamic host C configuration protocol
DHCP is used to assign IP addresses
name resolution is used to convert
numerical IP address values into a human
readable format known as the hostname
for example
104.95.5.15 is the numerical IP address
that refers to the hostname
whitehouse.gov host names are much
easier to remember given an IP address
you can obtain its corresponding
hostname accessing the machine over the
network becomes easier when you can type
the hostname instead of the IP address
you can view your system's hostname
simply by typing hostname with no
argument the special host name localhost
is associated with the IP address
127.0.0.1 and describes the machine you
are currently on which normally has
additional Network related IP addresses
let's get a feel for how the domain name
server works on a recent Ubuntu system
so first we need to log in
and when you log in we'll open up a
command line terminal because we're
going to do all our operations from the
command line
so I have done that by right clicking on
the desktop and then let me make a
bigger font
and I might as well go full screen while
I'm at it so
there are a couple of important files on
your system one is called
etcresult.conf
now on older Linux systems you didn't
have all this information at the top you
just had important thing here name
server
127.0.053 you're more likely to find
your name server is not a one two seven
one which all one two seven addresses
are on the actual machine but one nine
two one six eight that one that one for
instance would be a common thing
might point to your your wireless modem
which is attached to your internet
service provider for instance recent
systems use a systemd service called
systemd resolve D which works in a more
complicated way it makes a DNS server on
the local machine which caches the
results or previous searches so we're
not going to get into the details of
that but uh that's a recent development
that you'll find on newer machines
another important file is ETC hosts
this file is consulted before the domain
name server is consulted
so you'll see for instance here at the
bottom we've got two machines on the
local network we give their IP addresses
and a name that we can use to get at
them and you'll notice you can have more
than one name tied to an IP address so
for instance I could do
ping Theodore
and that's going to take me to 200 or I
could do ping uh beaver
it takes me to the same machine
now if I want to look at something which
isn't specified in that file or in fact
I can do that host uh Theodore
and it will go look at the file but if I
want to get something out on the
internet I could do most
linuxfoundation.org
and I'll get the both the ip4 and the
ip6 addresses here of the Linux
foundation and also information about
the mail services provided by the Linux
Foundation
I can do another utility for similar
information is NS lookup so I'll do that
and this lookup foundation.org
linksfoundation.org so you see you got
the same basic information a little more
compactly I've got here's the ip4
address and then the two ip6 addresses
another utility I can use is dig so
let's do dig Linux
foundation.org
and you'll see I once again got the
information about the IEP address and
then a lot more information about the
search to find that server so that's
just a little bit of what you can do
with DNS and some of the files that are
associated with it
network configuration files are
essential to ensure that interfaces
function correctly they are located in
the slash Etc directory tree however the
exact files used have historically been
dependent on the particular Linux
distribution and version being used
for deviant family configurations the
basic network configuration files could
be found under slash Etc Network while
for red hat and Susie family systems one
needed to inspect Etc sysconfig Network
modern systems emphasize the use of
network manager which we briefly
discussed when we considered graphical
system administration rather than keep
up with all the files and slash Etc
while the graphical versions of network
manager do look somewhat different in
different distributions the nmt UI
utility shown here varies almost not at
all as does even more sparse in mcli or
command line interface utility if you
are proficient in the use of gui's by
all means use them if you're working on
a variety of systems the lower level
utilities may make life easier
network interfaces are a connection
Channel between a device and a network
physically network interfaces can
proceed through a network interface card
or it can be more abstractly implemented
as software you can have multiple
network interfaces operating at once
specific interfaces can be brought up or
activated or brought down deactivated at
any time information about a particular
network interface or all network
interfaces can be reported by the IP and
ifconfig utilities which you may have to
run as the super user or at least give
the full path name IE spin ifconfig IP
is newer than ifconfig and has far more
capabilities but its output is uglier to
the human eye some new Linux
distributions do not install the older
net tools packets to which ifconfig
belongs and so you would have to install
it if you want to use it
to view the IP address you can do this S
Pen slash IP address show to view the
routing information slash S Pen slash IP
route show IP is a very powerful program
that can do many things older and more
specific utilities such as ifconfig and
Route are often used to accomplish
similar tasks a look at the relevant Man
pages can tell you much more about these
utilities
ping is used to check whether or not a
machine attached to the network can
receive and send data I.E confirms that
the remote host is online and is
responding check the status of the
remote host at the command prompt type
ping and then the hostname peeing is
frequently used for Network testing and
management however its usage can
increase Network load unacceptably hence
you can abort the execution of ping by
typing control C or by using the dash C
option which limits the number of
packets that ping will send before it
quits when when an execution stops a
summary is displayed
a network requires the connection of
many nodes data moves from source to
destination by passing through a series
of routers and potentially across
multiple networks servers maintain
routing tables containing the addresses
of each node in the network the IP
routing protocols enable routers to
build up a forwarding table that
correlates final destinations with the
next hop addresses one can use the route
utility or the newer IP route command to
view or change IP routing table to add
delete or modify specific static routes
to specific codes or networks this table
explains some commands that can be used
to manage IP routing
foreign
is used to inspect the route which the
data packet takes to reach the
destination host which makes it quite
useful for troubleshooting Network
delays and errors by using trace route
you can isolate connectivity issues
between hops which helps resolve them
faster to print the route taken by the
packet to reach the network host at the
command prompt type trace route and then
the address
now let's learn about some additional
networking tools networking tools are
very useful for monitoring and debugging
network problems such as network
connectivity and network traffic
let's get started on using more
networking tools to use more networking
tools open the command prompt to query
network interface connected to eth2 type
sudo eth tool eth0 and press enter to
display all active connections and
routing tables type
netstat-r and press enter all active
connections and routing tables are
displayed to scan open ports on a
network type sudo nmap Dash SP
10.0.2.15 24 and press enter
the open ports on a network are
displayed
browsers are used to retrieve transmit
and explore information resources
usually on the world wide web Linux
users commonly use both graphical and
non-graphical browser applications the
common graphical browsers used in Linux
are Firefox Google Chrome chromium
conquer and Opera sometimes you either
do not have a graphical environment to
work in or have reason not to use it but
still need to access web resources in
such a case you can use non-graphical
browsers such as these
sometimes you need to download files and
information but a browser is not the
best choice either because you want to
download multiple files or you want to
perform the action from a command line
or a script wget it's a command line
utility that can capably handle the
following types of downloads large file
downloads recursive downloads where a
web page refers to other web pages and
all are downloaded at once password
required downloads and multiple file
downloads to download a web page you can
simply type wget and then the URL and
then you can read the downloaded page as
a local file using a graphical or
non-graphical browser
besides downloading you may want to
obtain information about a URL such as
the source code being used curl can be
used from the command line or a script
to read such information curl also
allows you to save the contents of a web
page to a file as does wget you can read
a URL using curl URL for example if you
want to read freecodecamp.org type curl
HTTP colon freecodecamp.org
it to get the contents of a web page and
store it to a file type curl slash o
save.html and then the website address
the contents of the main index file at
the website will be saved in save.html
secure shell SSH is a cryptographic
network protocol used for secure data
communication it's also used for remote
services and other secure Services
between two devices on the network and
is very useful for administering systems
which are not easily available to
physically work on but to which you have
remote access to log in to a remote
system using your Sam username you can
just type SSH some system and press
enter SSH then prompts you for the
remote password you can also configure
SSH to securely allow your remote access
without typing a password each time
if you want to run as another user you
can do either ssh-l someone some system
or SSH someone at some system
to run a command on a remote system via
SSH at the command prompt you type SSH
sum system my command
we can also move files securely using
secure copy SCP between two networked
hosts SCP uses the SSH protocol for
transferring data to copy a local file
to a remote system at the command prompt
type sdp in the local file and then the
user at the remote system clones home
slash user and then you press enter you
will receive a prompt for the remote
password you can also configure sap so
that it does not prompt for a password
for each transfer
let's do a simple demonstration of using
secure shell and secure copy between two
virtual machines
Ubuntu machine and a Centos machine so
first from the Ubuntu machine let's try
to log into the Centos machine well
first I need to know the IP address of
both machines so I can do that with IP
and I'll say brief to get a condensed
output
um
addr for address shows
and I can see my address on this machine
is one seven two one six two four nine
one three three
I'll do the same command on the Cent OS
machine
and see the address is the same except
for the last byte or octet which is one
two nine
so first let's log into the Centos
machine from Ubuntu I do SSH student
at
172.16.249.129
and it's the first time I'm doing this
so it wants to make sure that I'm
authentic so I say yes
and now I have to give the password
and it's fine I'm on the central s
machine as you can see from the prompt
now in that command I really didn't have
to give student that because we're using
student account on both machines but it
never hurts to do that
so let me exit
now let's do from the Centos machine
Let's copy over directory
using SCP over to the Ubuntu machine
so let me do
scp-r for recursive to get the whole
directory and everything underneath it
uh and this time uh I won't as a home
student I'll copy the home student
directory I won't bother saying student
ad I'll just give the address
172.16-249.133
and I'll put it in the temp directory
once again it wants to make sure that
it's authentic so I'll say yes
and once again I have to give the
password
and it's copied over and if I go over to
the Ubuntu machine
and I look in the temp directory
I'll see the account is now there the
directory is now there so that's all
there is to do a pretty simple
demonstration of using secure shell and
secure copy
you have completed chapter 14. let's
summarize the key Concepts covered the
IP or Internet Protocol address is a
unique logical Network address that is
assigned to a device on a network ipv4
uses 32 bits for addresses and IPv6 uses
128 bits for addresses every IP address
contains both a network and a host
address field there are five classes of
network addresses available a b c d and
e DNS domain name system is used for
converting Internet domain and host
names to IP addresses the ifconfig
program is used to display current
Active network interfaces the commands
IP addr show and IP route show can be
used to view IP addresses and routing
information you can use ping to check if
the remote host is alive and responding
you can use the route utility program to
manage IP routing you can monitor and
debug networking problems using
networking tools
Firefox Google Chrome chromium and
Epiphany are the main graphical browsers
used in Linux
non-graphical or text browsers used in
Linux are links links and w3m you can
use wget to download web pages you can
use kernel to obtain information about
urls you can use SSH to run commands on
remote systems
we've reached the end of the course you
should now have a good working knowledge
of Linux from both a graphical and
command line perspective I mentioned at
the beginning of the course that there
is a text-based version of this course
Linked In the video's description that
version also has sections about the bash
shell and scripting Printing and local
security principles those won't be
relevant to everybody but feel free to
check that out if you want to learn
about those topics so good luck as you
use and administer Linux